доброго дня, я вітаю все, що ми починаємо
наша подія
він присвячений науково-дослідним установам
до інтеграції України до с
європейському дослідницькому просторі та було організовано
з боку міністерства
освіти і науки україни і я
хотів би звернути увагу всіх
наш
глядачів, які ви можете дивитися пряму трансляцію
українською чи англійською
Ви можете скористатися посиланням
на сайті міністерства
наукова освіта і дивитися наше
трансляція на початку
будь ласка, дозвольте мені сказати наступне
україни
проходить
істотні зміни зараз і для кожного
українська інтеграція
на європейський
союз і європейські цінності
є головною метою
це один з основних елементів
що в серці кожного з нас
Ось чому
що міністерство науки і
освіта робить це дуже важливо
для розвитку
наука та інновації в україні
так
Дозвольте
вітати заступника міністра науки
та освіти україни з питань
євроінтеграції Алексіс Коратов
florisios, добрий день шановний
колеги, дозвольте мені привітати
всі учасники наші колеги наші
колеги з європейської комісії
дякую за приєднання
дякуємо, що приєдналися до нашої події
дуже важливо для України
ми
тут
у день досліджень та інновацій в
україни і головне завдання підвести підсумки
результати того, що ми маємо
зроблено щодо інтеграції укр
наука та інновації переходять до
європейський дослідницький простір одним з головних
завдання полягає в тому
обговорити подальші пріоритети цього
інтеграції на 2022 рік і
пізніше я хотів би сказати
що
що для вас це важливо
важливо для України, і ми будемо
підтвердити це
в майбутніх презентаціях так
головне – активувати
діалог і спілкування з неурядовими організаціями
з науковою спільнотою с
представники інноваційної сфери
з представниками бізнесу
як далі
інтеграція в науку та інновації
також відправляється в європейський дослідницький простір
це підвищує рівень
популяризація наших
досягнення в цій галузі
і водночас хотів би сказати
і я хотів би подякувати
наш
уряд
за цей шлях до європейців
інтеграція наших
наук
я також хотів би сказати
що незважаючи
в
оновлена ​​дорожня карта
української інтеграції в
європейський дослідницький простір
ми також враховуємо
в
нова політика, яка була оновлена
Європейський Союз
нова політика розвитку науки
та інновації
і у нас будуть всі події
Я хотів би синхронізувати наші документи
подякувати нашим колегам з
європейської комісії за готовність до
приєднатися до сьогоднішнього заходу та представити
нова парадигма європейських досліджень
площа
а також
зрозуміти
Кращі країни, в тому числі і наша країна
я хотів би сказати, що наступного року
міністерство виконуватиме роботу, наскільки
наближаючись до цієї спільноти йде
і Україна отримає більше
доступ до європейських міжнародних
програми, такі як вартість та євро
інститут інновацій і технологій
і продовження
активація
програма європейського горизонту та інші
тож підводячи підсумок, я хотів би побажати всім
плідна робота учасників
цікаві ідеї
і за результатами сьогоднішнього дня
я впевнений, що Україна
буде продовжувати інтегруватися в
Європейська дослідницька зона дуже дякую
до вашої уваги
дякую, пане Олексій
я хотів би сказати наступне
Україна розпочала свій шлях до
наука набагато швидше
і дослідники є тими, хто
роблячи світ відкритим і
без меж, і вони першими
усвідомити, що наука є міжнародною
але інтеграція україни
в гм
е
a розпочався у 2015 році, коли була укладена перша угода
про асоціацію було підписано європ
змінюється україна змінюється і
інтеграційний процес є безперервним
процес, чому я хотів би зараз
надати слово
до представника с
гм
до
до голови експертної групи з питань
питання інтеграції на європ
області дослідження Григорія Масалевича він буде
розкажіть нам, що було зроблено
міністерства науки і освіти в
ця область, будь ласка, floresius, дякую
міс олександра
відкрийте презентацію
я хотів би сказати наступне
Повернутися в
2015, коли
була укладена угода про асоціацію
підписаний
новий закон
на
був прийнятий новий закон
і
одна зі статей цього закону
зазначив, що Україна приєднається до
Європейський дослідницький простір у 2018 році
колеги
гм
від міністерства науки затверджено
перша версія дорожньої карти
інтеграція України до європейської
область дослідження це рамка
документ
це
був на роботі кілька років і в
2019 прийнято рішення
оновити цей документ
тому що європейський союз
розвивався
весь цей час він пропонував нові ідеї
і нові виклики нові завдання
Я намагаюся зрозуміти, як переключитися
наступний слайд так
була створена робоча група
в національній раді на
розвиток технологій
так само була група номер три
це називалося євроінтеграція і це
працював над оновленням дорожньої карти на
про інтеграцію України в епоху
цю робочу групу
працював
разом з представниками с
міністерств освіти і науки
і вони розробили документ, який був
затверджується міністерством
у 2021 році
і
я розповім вам більше про
кроки цього документа так це
документ
має вісім пріоритетів, але я думаю
Гм, є шість пріоритетів і
інші два є окремими пріоритетами і це
має конкретні завдання цілі і
індикатори
тому пріоритет номер один
підвищення ефективності нац
дослідницька система
то що зміг зробити міністерство
цього року досягти
цілі цього пріоритету
Поперше
чотири сторони
дослідження проводилося для того, щоб
гм
[Музика]
так
так і до гм
затвердити список ум
короткострокові речі, які необхідно зробити
а також уряд
теж все підтримав
гм
розроблено законопроект
внести зміни до закону України
про наук.-техн
експертиза
це був список законодавчих
ініціативи
це відбулася окрема подія
рік був нарешті
підведення підсумків складання перших конспектів
та здійснення державної підтримки
пріоритетні наукові напрямки в
вищих навчальних закладах
є результат державних атестацій
і було 66 угод
міністерство науки і освіти с
загальне фінансування близько 100 млн
тяжкий
цього року ми запустили a
конкурсний відбір проектів і
робота під зовнішнім інструментом і
це допомога з боку європейців
союз і це
Конкурс стартував у листопаді 2021 року і
наші дослідницькі проекти приймаються до
20 грудня
до для відшкодування для фінансування um
за рахунок відшкодування в
2020 рік
і 2021 рік
так
Національний науково-дослідний фонд україни
фінансування проектів і
я впевнений, що всі ви в курсі
це фінансування збільшується від
рік у рік і це одне з основних
показники в т.ч
до
[Музика]
в тому числі з точки зору
застосування цього документа
також цього року
ми збільшуємо фінанси Антарктики
дослідження і
в гм
в майбутньому Україна також матиме гм
арктичний
гм
дослідження цього року Україна купила
криголам
немає сфери
та україною
буде
відправити
наше дослідження
до академіка Вернанського дослідження
район або станція
тож це були основні системні зміни
які були в межах першого пріоритету
пріоритет спільного вирішення проблем
викликані глобальними викликами
і деякі речі, які були зроблені
міністерство освіти і науки с
україни
тому я зараз розповім про них
пріоритети
Я вважаю, що одна з головних проблем для
наша експертна група з інтеграції в епоху
цього року
був
забезпечити, щоб Україна приєдналася до
далі
каркас
програма з досліджень та інновацій
Європа дзвонила
горизонт європи
цього року у нас було три раунди
технічні переговори, потім три раунди
офіційних переговорів і 12 числа
жовтня 2021 року
ми підписали угоду про Україну
приєднання
рамкова програма
європейський горизонт, а також програма на
дослідження
атом євро
також
цього року
українські дослідники-новатори
приєднавшись до ініціативи
в рамках різноманітних конкурсів на
європейський зелений
угоди міністерства освіти і науки
україни
на прохання
для багатьох дослідників
веде активні переговори
що стосується приєднання собівартості
програма йде ця програма дозволить
українських дослідників
брати участь у спільних заходах с
європейських колег, а також ініціювати
такі події в Україні самі по собі
сподіваюся, що в 2022 році
ми зможемо стати
повноправний член цієї організації
також
йдуть активні консультації
на
Європейський інститут інновацій і
технології
у сфері спільних інновацій та
дослідження
минулого року було проведено багато роботи
проведена аналітична робота
що стосується приєднання
багато дослідницьких цілей європ
Союз 49 з них було створено і я сподіваюся
що раз
закон
україни ратифіковано закон
україни до приєднання до ум
програма горизонту Європи ми зможемо
до
розпочати цей процес без затримок
цього року
ми продовжили програму підключення додатків
і ми приступили до
yap connect частина 2 і ми поговоримо
докладніше про це в
конкретні панельні дискусії
пріоритет 2b
оптимальне використання державних інвестицій в
дослідницьких інфраструктур також багато
тут виконана робота і вона є
триває
спочатку
концепція державної програми с
розвиток дослідницької інфраструктури був
затверджено на рр
2021-2026 міністерство разом с
інші органи виконавчої влади
розроблено проект
програми розвитку
дослідницькі інфраструктури
і це буття
м-м домовилися з міністерством
фінанси україни
ми
закінчив аудит дослідження
інфраструктури в україні
за інструменти політичної підтримки
програми горизонту, і вона почнеться
у 2021 році європейські партнери ум
підтримав цей проект фінансово і я
думаю, що протягом одного місяця ви це зробите
дізнайтеся більше про цілі, які ви отримаєте
краще познайомитися з командою
тема цього проекту і це
процес триватиме
також
розпочато роботу зі створення реєстру
дослідницькі інфраструктури
цей проект вже є
4 000
частини інформації
і цей проект є спеціальним модулем
в
інформаційна система та команда міністерства
працює над цим
і наступного року
цей реєстр буде оновлено
наскільки я пам'ятаю
навколо
установ
сказав «так» на наш лист
до пілотування і як далеко
збирання інформації йде і створення
відповідний портал, і я думаю, що
наступного року
кількість таких закладів буде
вище
щодо пріоритету номер три безкоштовно
ринку праці дослідників тут я б
люблять зосередитися на кроках
які про те, на що спрямовані
підтримка молодих дослідників в Україні
тому було проведено багато змагань
підтримка
ну молодь
наукова молодь
ці змагання продовжуються в
міністерство науки
та освіти україни
і вони також здійснюються
національний фонд дослід
є рада молодих вчених
активно працює
я впевнений, що ви бачили його активність
це в рамках міністерства освіти
і наука також
закон був опрацьований
про надання підтримки
і для молодих вчених
постановою Кабінету Міністрів
був
затверджено в березні цього року
було змінено законодавство
щодо працевлаштування молодих вчених
йде
працевлаштування та розвиток кар'єри
пріоритет номер чотири
рівність та комплексний гендерний підхід
в науці
наш
дирекція діяла
в цій області
і ми створили робочу групу
розробити метод
рекомендації
щодо гендерних аудитів у
вища установа
закладів, а також міжн
Концепція міжнародного форуму була
розроблений він був присвячений жінкам в
наук
також у нас буде окрема панель
обговорення, і ми запросимо
Компанія l'oreal і наше міністерство
є
готуючись до приєднання до глобальної
форум на рівні ум
un
у 2022 році і буде присвячений
[Музика]
успіхи жінок
в стовбурі
в науці
тому пріоритет 5a передача знань і
відкриті інновації тут я хотів би сказати
наступні
цього року
нарешті любити україну за наміром
інтенсифікація наукових парків була
прийнято міністерством розроблено ряд
з
законодавчі акти на підтримку
інновації, тому це проект запуску
стимулювання передачі технологій
законопроект та зміни до ст
бюджетного кодексу та
ці два законопроекти є в
парламент україни також акція
план виконання в
стратегія розвитку с
було затверджено нововведення до 2030 року
також ми запустили онлайн-платформу
гм
для спілкування між учасниками
в інноваційному процесі наука за
бізнес
us2bm
Ми також
приєднався до глобальної пілотної програми ООН
підтримувати країни в розвитку
дорожні карти для досягнення сталого
цілі розвитку через науку
технології та інновації на
основи розумної спеціалізації
цього року ми делегували
[Музика]
представники від україни до
форум Європейської інноваційної ради
тепер я хотів би зосередитися на пріоритеті 5p
мова йде про відкриту науку та цифрові технології
інновації
у травні приблизно ми створили a
робоча група з відкритої науки розвивати
національний план дій для
реалізація принципів відкритості
наук
і сьогодні
у нас буде a
конкретна ця панельна дискусія з цього приводу
і ми розповімо вам більше про
проект цього документа
і я сподіваюся, що в 2022 р
цей національний план, над яким працювали
по
буде представлена ​​національна група
для
Кабінет міністрів також
Поки що міністерство робить велику роботу
як створення національної електронної
інформаційна система йде
створюючи його та наповнюючи його
окремих модулів ця робота буде продовжена
принаймні на наступні два роки
і ми поговоримо більше про систему
пізніше
пріоритет номер шість
міжнародне співробітництво
ключовими досягненнями тут є
слідуючи
прийняття двох законів
на
договорів про наук. і
технологічне співробітництво з ЄС
та Сполучених Штатів Америки
також Україна офіційно приєдналася до
здійснення спільного морського
Порядок денний щодо Чорного моря та с
програма стратегічних досліджень інновацій
для чорного моря
також
люди помітили, що президент
має
[Музика]
прийняв ступінь для розвитку флоту
морський флот
та відповідне дослідження
а Україна отримала два
дослідницькі судна для дослідження
криголам носфера і бельгіка
судно, яке буде використано
нашими колегами
від міністерства природних ресурсів
та міністерство охорони навколишнього середовища або
екологія
і міністерство буде працювати
на
зміна кількості таких досліджень
структури, які можуть забезпечити
дослідження в морі
він намагатиметься збільшити цю кількість
я хотів би сказати кілька слів
що стосується двостороннього співробітництва
україни в галузі науки і
техніка йде
тому слайди презентації мають
країни
котрий
ну має
які мають двостороннє співробітництво
з україною
і деякі з цього добре кількість
ці країни будуть
рости
і міністерство
працює
про те, що не має 20 20 12 чи 15 країн
але в 2025 році
біля
майбутнє
тому ми профінансували
106 двосторонніх дослідницьких програм у 2021 році
на загальну суму
закінчено
17 мільйонів
доходи
так
щодо інтеграції України в
Європейський дослідницький простір щодо
дорожня карта
першочергові завдання
так
гм
тому пул експертів
створено і люди працюватимуть
з
гм
рада ЄС
і
з іраком
також
буде державна політика відкритості
наука я сподіваюся
що
е, парламент україни в
початок
2022 підтримає Україну
закон
про ратифікацію договору про приєднання
горизонт і це буде дуже
важливо, тому що укр
буде
отримати додатковий доступ
до науки та інновацій і в порядку
для реалізації цієї ознаки ми відкриваємо цей закон
до
плануємо відкрити координаційний центр
і працює національний портал
на цю тему
і ми плануємо оновити та створити нову
команда гм
сильні контактні точки
який би працював
про українських дослідників та новаторів
мати ще кращі успіхи, коли це приходить
до
працює над цією програмою
горизонт Європи та Іраку
ми плануємо розширити участь
Україна в Іраку
і, як я вже сказав, ми плануємо
приєднатися до програми витрат і приєднатися до всіх
різноманітні можливості та можливості
і ми плануємо розвиватися
це
дослідження в ц
антарктичний і, можливо, арктичний також
в загальному
я б хотів
до
закінчити свою презентацію тут
цього і наступного року йде подяка
Вам за вашу увагу і я хотів би
спитати
всі підприємці дослідники і
новаторів україни активно
приєднатися до можливостей, які має Україна
на сьогодні в рамках інтеграції
до європейського дослідницького простору дякую
Дуже дякую
дуже дякую, це вражає
скільки коштує міністерство науки і
освіта змогла зробити всюди
цього року
я розумію, що ви почали в
2015 і 2019, але наскільки я знаю це
всю процедуру
складання цієї дорожньої карти було фактично виконано
з європейським підходом
і брати участь у науковому співтоваристві
і біла громадськість і україна в
унісон співзвучний з іншими країнами
тому що
тих, хто
країни, які були державами-членами
ЄС протягом тривалого часу йдуть так само
шлях, але є різниця між
українське та європейське законодавство
є якісь проблеми
юридично
або виконання законодавчих
додаток
я можу прокоментувати це
насправді наш
активна наукова спільнота є
починаючи з 2017 року.
пропонував досить активно
що
це
Дорожня карта затверджується на рівні
постановою Кабінету Міністрів
але, сподіваюся, ви розумієте це в
для затвердження такого указу необхідно
відповідне фінансування відповідне
кількість грошей і зрозуміти в
якого року
ми повинні мати можливість досягти
відповідні завдання цієї дорожньої карти
Я говорив про 50-60 відсотків
із завдань
які вказані в дорожній карті
ті, які я не згадав
або підвісна реалізація або
ми не маємо
людські фінансові чи інші ресурси та
Україна не має до цього жодного доступу
тому що ми не приєдналися до наступного
рамкова програма і це міра
для подальшої роботи
і сподіваюся
ми
як у нас
наказ міністерства науки
та освіти україни
виконувати
всі необхідні заходи з
фінансові інструменти від міністерства
з
науки і освіти та нац
Академія наук триває
приєднання до
виконання певних кроків
це вже робить
в рамках розуміння
наскільки важливі процеси
цю дорожню карту
дуже дякую за цю відповідь i
є ще багато запитань, я впевнений
що
глядачі онлайн мають ще більше
питання
скажіть, будь ласка, як можна
наукове співтовариство сприяє досягненню
ці завдання
міністерство
ну те, що я був, я б сказав
є багато людей, багато ініціативних
науковців
що приходять щотижня разом із ними
ідеї та
Я згадав раду молодих
науковців
під парасолькою міністерства науки
і освіта тут, в кімнаті у нас
десятки людей
які пропонують, хто пропонує свою допомогу
тиждень для створення um
певні рамкові документи та
міністерство науки і освіти в
його
можливості в межах своїх можливостей є
створення робочих груп, я б сказав
це якщо ти
див. певний
доступний час
хм, якщо у вас є достатньо часу для чернетки
an
аналітичний документ, щоб запропонувати
конкретні кроки вивчення фінансових або юридичних
інструменти, які є
вже впроваджено в певних країнах ЄС
країни до
виконати спільний поділ о
час від часу поновлювався
в рамках діяльності
і це сталося в Європі
дослідження
області, тому міністерство відкрите для таких
особистий
ініціативи, і ви можете прийти до нас
прямо писати листи
запропонуйте свій
ідеї для робочих груп, для яких ми відкриті
співробітництво
я дуже дякую тобі
мені шкода, що у нас не вистачає часу
продовжити наш порядок денний міністерство
робити це чудово, ти це знаєш
чудово усвідомлювати це сьогодні
підходи міністерств орієнтовані на
громадська робота так тепер дорога
колеги
перейдемо до наступної частини нашого
програму, і ми це добре знаємо
Європа теж змінюється
і вони е
затвердження нових документів і ми
раді бачити, що європейці о
їх представники європ
спілка бере участь, ми також повинні
вивчення
процеси, що відбуваються в ЄС і
реалізуйте їх і введіть у наш
по-своєму, як щойно сказав пан Грегорі, Україна
продовжує рухатися вперед
і продовжується
покращення нашої практики на основі
досконалість європейських країн так зараз
ми приводимо до обговорення міс
Анна Сапе
Сподіваюся, наші технічні помічники зможуть
перевести її з Інтернету до
наша кімната
ms anna, ви готові приєднатися до нас і
вимовте свою промову, добрий день
ранок міс і ми будемо мати
синхронний переклад
доброго ранку, міс Анна, ми раді
Ви на нашому заході, давайте представимо
наша колега г-жа Анна представник
головне управління з досліджень і
нововведення європейської комісії
пані Анна, ми знаємо, що Європа триває
рухатися вперед очевидно і нещодавно
були затверджені нові законодавчі акти
пакт про знаки і покоління
скажіть, будь ласка, серед них
Які
в
останні події в Європі
комісія, будь ласка, слово за вами
дуже радий бути тут доброго ранку
я також трохи покажу тобі
трохи, що відбувається в Європі
область дослідження
і я просто почну прямо зі свого
презентація
тож, як ви згадали, є процес
Відродження відбувається в Європі
область дослідження, тому я почну трохи
про це розповім трохи про
хронологія що сталося що
документи важливі, тому пакт для
Дослідження інновацій є частиною цього
тоді у нас також нова ера управління
на основі нещодавно прийнятої ради
висновки
з яких є порядок денний повітряної політики
частина, де ми також сподіваємося на
україни брати активну участь у та
у нас буде новий процес моніторингу як
ну і я теж трохи поговорю
про наступний крок європейця
область дослідження
тому, насамперед, що таке новий європеєць
це свого роду ідея мати це
єдиний безтілесний ринок для дослідження
інновації та технології в ЄС
де всі країни збираються разом
вдосконалити свою політику в галузі досліджень і
також має бути вільний рух
знання та інновації дослідників
і цей процес почався в новому
європейський
Процес дослідження розпочався у 2018 році
європейський дослідницький простір як ідея
насправді від
2000 вже і було чотири
стратегічні цілі, які ми розпочали
з одним було визначення пріоритетів
інвестиції в дослідження та інновації
підвищити охоплення ринку, але й покращити
доступ до досконалості і, звичайно
посилити мобільність дослідників
і безкоштовно
вільний потік знань і
технології
я не знаю, о, так, ви можете побачити
наступний слайд, щоб дати вам трохи
огляду того, що сталося під час ми
оживити це почалося з
спілкування про нову еру досліджень
і інновації в 2020 році, а потім у нас було
також висновки ради, які підтримали
це
перезапуск і оновлення європейської
область дослідження
і в минулому році у нас був експерт
група, яку називали повітряною формою для
переходу
і вони зустрічалися приблизно 13 разів
і включав усі країни-члени
і ми також мали три семінари з rni
зацікавлені сторони
і теми, які ми висвітлювали, були
управління, яке ми хотіли змінити, але
також політичний порядок денний, про який я буду говорити
трохи більше про згодом і ми
детально розглянув пілот чотирьох епох
дії, які стосуються тем
зелений водень пластикові пірати
Європейська відкрита наукова хмара та
платформа талантів
і всю роботу в цій експертній групі
потім призвело до пропозиції пакту за
дослідження та інновації, які відбулися
у липні 2021 року
і це
є єдиним у своєму роді документом, оскільки для
перший раз він дійсно збирає все
цінності, які ми маємо для нашого дослідження
та інновації в Європі
і насправді лише нещодавно цей документ
прийнято 26 листопада
і ми також мали прийняття
висновки ради, які
дайте показати нам шлях, як нова ера
управління має працювати і які
перші дії, над якими ми будемо працювати
у майбутньому
щоб дати вам трохи подробиць
про що там пакт
насправді чотири
області в ньому ми маємо принципи
пріоритетні напрямки інвестицій
але й координація політики
і тут ви можете побачити принципи, які
які були зібрані разом з
держав-членів, що наше дослідження і
інновації
слід зосередитися на, і вони розділені
в трійку
верхні заголовки, я думаю, підтримуються
цінності, які працюють краще і працюють
разом
тоді у нас також є пріоритетні напрямки для
спільні дії, які також поділяються на
чотири різні області, і вони дають a
більше
конкретний погляд на те, чого ми хочемо досягти
у наступному році, щоб вони дійсно показали
вони перекладають значення в
які напрямки для дій де
де робити, де ми насправді хочемо
працювати разом як в Європі, так і в
найближчі роки, і я не буду вдаватися в подробиці
але ви бачите, що вони дуже охоплюють
різні теми від таких відкритих знаків до
координація інвестицій RNI
і ці першочергові дії залишаються
досить широкі, але потім вони інформують
конкретні дії політичного порядку денного
який розрахований на наступні два роки
де ми насправді маємо бетон
дії, які скажуть нам, чого ми хочемо
працювати над
ми також маємо
область, яка зосереджена на інвестиціях
і реформи і тут країни-члени
підтвердив ціль у три відсотки
ВВП ЄС та
інвестиції в дослідження та розробки
і в якості доповнення маємо деякі
підцілі на національному рівні, що
держави-члени це фактично беруть до уваги
може привести нас до цієї 3 цілі, яка має
був
було частиною дослідницьких інновацій для
довгий час
і як четвертий компонент
пакт досліджень та інновацій ми
мати моніторинг та координацію
і тут ми маємо різні нові елементи
це спростить
координації та моніторингу та в
порівняння з тим, як було раніше
розглянемо це трохи докладніше
пізніше, але у нас буде політика
платформи, а також політику помилок і
гендерна 18-місячна звітність та a
табло
то навіщо нам насправді потрібна нова ера
управління та чому ми все це зробили
працювати
тому, як ми всі знаємо, є
багато нових контактів відбувається в
політична сфера досліджень та інновацій
у нас є ці чотири стратегії нової ери
цілі, але також
дослідження та інновації повинні робити як
частина для включення цифрового та зеленого
переходи та інші міжгалузеві
цілі політики і, звичайно
ми повинні покращити інтерфейси та
обмін знаннями з іншими відповідними
галузі галузевої політики
і як цього потрібно досягти
ми хочемо надати перевагу кращій політиці
ініціатив, але ми також хочемо збільшити
політична власність має більшу ефективність
переклад на активний і що може
відбувається лише через координацію в
союзу національного та регіонального рівня та оф
курс у партнерстві з асоційованими
країни
але також дуже важливо мати a
кращого та тіснішого залучення
зацікавлених сторін і все це дало
поштовх до редизайну
сучасне управління
зміцнити його спроможність
реалізація і тому ми маємо
пакт про дослідницькі інновації, але
також політичний порядок денний ери мати більше
посилення політичної власності
де країни-члени вирішують і які
дії, яких вони насправді хочуть
участь в
щоб показати вам трохи того, як ми
уявіть, що це спрацює в наступні роки
буде короткострокова політика
порядок денний
який базується на пакті про дослідження
та інновацій, які є довгостроковими
документ, який протягом приблизно 10 років є як
уявне
часовий графік та ера політичного порядку денного
в
дії на два-три роки
а потім звідти ми перейдемо до
реалізація, яка потім також, звичайно
відбудеться на національному рівні, тому ви
розглядати жовту частину як національну
рівні, на яких буде здійснюватися координація політики
відбутися
а де реформи та інвестиції
також станеться і тоді все це
звісно будемо відстежувати, побачимо
який прогрес ми досягаємо в
різні дії, і це буде тоді
знову інформувати про політику нової ери
і нові дії, які ми хочемо
зосередитися на є два основних
принципи, які свідчать про це
Загальний процес виглядає наступним чином
функцій, тож ми починаємо з того, що хочемо
робити і це потрібно виконувати і
ось як ми потім налаштували управління
а також налаштувати дії
і тоді це також дуже важливо
ми хочемо, щоб зацікавлених сторін було більше
центрального в цьому загальному процесі ми не займаємо
хочуть, щоб це були лише країни-члени
процесу, тому що для того, щоб мати факт
прогрес, який ми маємо структурно залучити
ну зацікавлені сторони
і це потім призвело до такого роду
нове управління, звичайно, ми ще
мають
ті самі актори, які були в нас раніше
була рада, яка й досі робить це
політичного керівництва і приймає всі
ініціативи, такі як пакт і
перший політичний порядок денний у листопаді
ми все ще маємо роль erac котрий
буде стратегічною політикою високого рівня
орган, що надає ранні поради щодо стратегічних
політичні орієнтації, а й політику
вимоги
але ми продовжуємо мати це нове тіло
форум епохи
який тепер також матиме всі
підгрупи, тому не існує безперервних
підгрупи та ери в eric більше
усі потенційні нові підгрупи будуть
par буде частиною форуму цієї ери
і цей орган існує для політики
координації, а також для
реалізація і тут ми уявляємо
мають бути асоційованими країнами
залучені, але також зацікавлені сторони та
минулий рік дуже це показав
це прекрасне місце або чудове
групі, щоб мати гарну взаємодію та до
дійсно просувати вперед те, чого ми хочемо
досягти в
у новій європейській дослідницькій зоні
щоб показати вам трохи більше, що
будуть завдання і як це буде
досягнуто на форумі в нову епоху
тому, звісно, ​​вони будуть там
буде координація та підготовка
політичного порядку денного епохи
нинішній, але й майбутній
тож на наступні півроку будемо за
На прикладі обговорюємо дії 20
дії, які ми маємо в даний час
політичну програму і подивіться, хто з них ми
фактично може реалізуватися в державі-члені
рівні, а також у асоційованій країні
рівень
а потім ми разом розробимо їх
відповідні дії, а також спільне проектування
майбутні відповідні дії, і це повинно
допомогти державам-членам у фактичній реалізації
дії
і в кінці дня виконати
цикл політики ми поговоримо про те, як
контролювати та оцінювати їх
щоб потім мати прогрес у наступному
епоха політичний порядок денний
то як це буде досягнуто ми
звичайно, буде двостороннім
діалоги з державами-членами ми будемо
обмінюватися найкращими практиками
але також мають структурне залучення
зацікавлених сторін у нас є платформа, яку ми будемо
мати платформу, яка дозволить нам це зробити
обмінюватися цими передовими практиками, і ми
матиме табло с
індикатори для фактичного моніторингу того, що є
відбувається в європейському дослідницькому просторі
і тоді, звичайно, у нас буде під
групи на важливі теми
зануритися глибше
і як безкоштовні партнерські знання
хаб і рульова панель eos будуть працювати
у тісній співпраці з авіафорумом
також інформувати нас про їх політику
і щоб дати вам уявлення про те, що я говорив
багато про порядок денний повітряної політики
дайте вам уявлення про те, як це виглядає
у нас є ці 20 дій, які ви можете
див
сині теми це блакитні
виділені заголовки це
теми, які випливають із пакту
тому що ми інформуємо про ці дії на основі
пріоритетні сфери політики, які ми хочемо
працювати над
і на даний момент у нас є 20 запропонованих
дії, і я не буду вдаватися до подробиць
Ви бачите тут першу їх частину
а потім ви бачите тут другу частину
їх у них дійсно широкий асортимент і
це буде наступні півроку, що ми
буде працювати на них, ви також бачите, що вони
іноді все ще дуже не сплять, тому в
висновки ради ми маємо ці дії
назви, і тоді ми маємо певні результати
але як це буде досягнуто, що буде
бути роботою наступного півріччя
і ми матимемо пояснювальні документи
на кожному з них з кроками, які ми
хочу взяти, але ми також обговоримо
який із них буде насправді
продовжується, тому що нам потрібна підтримка
половина країн-членів, які хочуть
брати участь і, звичайно, ми також будемо
запитати про асоційовані країни
участі, тож нам потрібно побачити, який із
ці дії зроблять крок вперед
а які ні
тут ви бачите уявний моніторинг
обробити, як це буде виглядати в
майбутнього, тож ми отримаємо внески від
держав-членів на політичну платформу
що в основному буде
веб-сайт для
взаємодії, то ми матимемо a
інформаційна панель, на якій у вас будуть дані
на рівні держав-членів, але й більше
загальнодоступне табло з даними рівня ЄС
щоб стежити за тим, що відбувається
дії, але також
гм невизначені показники, які є
важливо з європейських досліджень
площа
як друга частина у нас ще буде
звітність
для кожної країни-члена, але також
18 місяців
звіт про загальний прогрес
і про це буде звіт
здійснення політики арабської епохи
порядок денний загалом
Перш ніж ми перейдемо до ваших запитань, я просто
хочу показати вам наступні кроки
буде взято, що буде взято в цьому
площа
тому в першу чергу ми встановимо
форум нової ери, тому що ми
Минулий рік був епохою форуму
перевести цю експертну групу
яка відбулася в грудні цього року
і тепер у нас буде більш стабільний a
більш стабільну групу, яка також буде включати
зацікавлені сторони, а також буде включати
асоційовані країни як спостерігачі
брати участь у форумі помилок і
тут, як я вже сказав, ми поговоримо про
виконання помилкових дій
підготувати майбутні оновлення, а також дуже
багато говорити про те, як ми хочемо
здійснювати моніторинг
і що нам потрібно для моніторингу
бути корисним для держав-членів і для
асоційовані країни
так як ви бачите інший інший великий
кроком також є налаштування моніторингу
і де ми повинні представити перший
його версія наш перший фреймворк
версія в середині 2022 року
а потім те, що дуже важливо зробити
більш конкретні дії ми матимемо
пояснювальні документи по кожному з них
показати та допомогти державам-членам і
асоційованих країн, щоб вибрати які
дії, яких вони насправді хочуть
участь в
і це буде головна робота 2022 року
тож це з мого боку, щоб дати вам
перше враження, а тепер я дуже щаслива
щоб відповісти на будь-які запитання
мають
ті
Здравствуйте
дуже дякую, тому я маю
наступне запитання
асоційовані країни, такі як Україна
особливе місце займає європейський
комісія
побачити деякі пріоритетні напрямки роботи з
асоційовані країни, можливо, є
деякі нові інструменти
працювати разом і поглиблювати таку роботу
так, асоціація з горизонтом Європи
це, так би мовити, горизонт Європи
дослідження та рамкова програма, але
Європейський дослідницький простір ще ширший
ніж це, тому у вас є дзвінки
програма Horizon Europe, де ви
курс тісно пов'язаний з тому, що
ви асоційована країна
але тоді європейський дослідницький простір має
ширші дії, ніж це, і вони
не всі фінансуються за рахунок досліджень і
рамкова програма, але спец
Механізм у вас насправді такий
немає спеціального механізму, тому що
ви будете брати участь як держави-члени
візьме участь у форумі епохи
так
де відбуватимуться всі дії і
де ми будемо говорити про
асоційованими країнами є
запрошено до участі
гм, як спостерігачів і фактично повинні
бути частиною дії, що відбувається
на європейський дослідницький простір, так би мовити
о, дуже дякую
міс Анна, я хотів би запитати у вас
на вашу думку наступне запитання
що може зробити Україна
щоб
інтегрувати в
Європейський дослідницький простір наступного року швидше
особливо беручи до уваги
зміни, які відбулися в європейській зоні
Я думаю, що це буде дуже важливо
частина обговорень авіафоруму
тому що, як я сказав, 20 дій, які ми
на даний момент це те, де ми
буде працювати також дуже важливо
щоб Україна побачила, чого вони хочуть
брати участь у
і висновки ради власне
передбачити, що асоційовані країни можуть як
ну гм
скажіть, які дії вони хочуть виконати
брати участь і тільки в діях, які
мають достатню підтримку з боку держав-членів
потім буде висунуто, тому я думаю це
є також
область важливості на те, як
україни
може
може більше інтегруватися в європейці
область дослідження, дивлячись на які з
ці дії насправді мають відношення до
нас і в яких із цих дій ми робимо
насправді хочу взяти участь
дуже дякую це було дуже
цікавого було багато
цікава інформація також для
міністерство освіти і науки в
україни, а також з усієї
науковій спільноті в україні дякую
тобі так багато
Європейська комісія за всі кроки
що ви робите для розвитку європейського
області дослідження, а також запросити таких
країни, як Україна
і ми сподіваємося, що наступного року або в
в майбутньому це буде ця співпраця
покращений, дуже дякую
так ми
чули, що Україна і міністерство
освіти науки в україні є
багато робить для впровадження нових інструментів
і механізми
деякі з цих механізмів добре відомі
європейською спільнотою
наукове співтовариство таке безінструментальне
курс
і Україна не є постійним членом, але
ще багато дослідників особливо
тих дослідників, які працюють
в
науки і працювати в бізнесі прикладної
наук
тому буде цікаво
почути більше про можливості
Україна приєднується до цієї сфери і зараз
ми б хотіли
гм
до
приєднатися до, щоб запросити учасника узбережжя
гм
міс Каталін Альфонді, координатор
програми в європ
програма Я сподіваюся, що Каталін з нами
доброго дня
гм, міс Каталін, будь ласка
розкажіть про можливості
україни бере участь у цій програмі
будь ласка
перевіримо підключення
ми вас добре чуємо, дуже дякую
ми бачимо вас дуже добре, дякую
ми раді вітати вас
на нашому заході, і я щойно поділився з
наш
глядачів, яких ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
що ти маєш сказати
щоб дізнатися більше про те, як україна
може приєднатися до берегової програми, і ми сподіваємося на це
ви зможете розповісти нам більше про
потенційні можливості для України
і що ви про це думаєте
як ми можемо цього досягти, як ми можемо
досягти поглиблення співпраці для України
в цій зоні, будь ласка, ваша підлога
дуже дякую
Мене звати Катаріна Альфорді, я глобальна
Керівник завдання та політика створення мереж
офіцер за вартістю об'єднання
і сьогодні я приніс тобі маленький подарунок
презентація про пояснення
яка вартість, як це працює, і я сподіваюся
мати
питання про те, які переваги
брати участь у витратах і сподіватися мати
згодом питання про все це
ви можете знати додатково
про вартість
в першу чергу вартість - це
міжурядова організація ім
членами її членами є країни
на даний момент членами є 38 країн
один кооператор і один партнер
члена, як ви можете побачити його на карті
у нас є різні кольори для
різні країни-члени
тому що вартість глибоко залучена
поширення досконалості та
розширити участь у європейських ух
дослідження та інновації
схеми фінансування і тому ми маємо
певні конкретні заходи для
так звана ціль включення витрат
країни ті країни, чиї
можливо, знадобиться дослідницький потенціал
додаткова допомога
бути однаково ух бути
повністю і
найкраще брати участь у цій структурі в
ці програми
є гм
якщо ви думаєте про програму витрат
є три основні пріоритети
ну
хм формування
вартість діяльності, яка є як i
згадані для просування та поширення
досконалість
сприяти недисциплінарним дослідженням
прагнучи до
знайти
рішення та нові знання створюють нові
знання в науці
та для підвищення кар'єри молодих людей
дослідників і надати їм можливість бути
керівники досліджень для
найближче майбутнє
коли ми говоримо про просування та
поширення досконалості
звичайно е
вартість має європейський фокус, але це не так
ну
гм
його діяльність пов'язана не тільки з ним
до Європи це також
його проекти та дії
і особливо дослідників, які є
працюють у них тісно й добре
підключений глобально, як ви можете побачити це на
карта
крос країни
є
це не тільки крос країни, але
також всі
країни земної кулі, дослідники яких
вітаються і можуть брати участь у вартості
на цій карті ви можете побачити Україну як буття
один з вартості поблизу сусідньої країни новий
сусідня країна – це країна, яка має
закритий
географічне відношення до т. зв
країни
і
це країни, де дослідники
не тільки вітають і заохочують
брати участь у першому, але також доступний
і мають право на отримання
відшкодування за участь
коли ми говоримо про міждисциплінарність
це приклад витратної дії і
вона представлена ​​та її учасниками
що представляють різні
наукові основи наукових галузей
і, можливо, кількість гм
дослідників з певної галузі
які займаються тими ж витратами
і говорити про третій пріоритет
про кар’єру молодих дослідників
цей слайд розроблено по порядку
показати це в будь-якій кар’єрі
етап
дослідники можуть залучатися
як а
попередня діяльність або як наступна діяльність
активність до вартості дій для підтримки їх
кар'єра
і коротко, чому це вигідно
брати участь у витратах
є, звичайно, важливі наукові
елементи до цього також є
кар’єрні можливості, які можуть бути
про що слід згадати і
додатково отримати
додаткові адміністративні дослідження
адміністративні та управлінські навички
наукові переваги є одним з
іншим є те, щоб бути членом
визнаних провідних наук
міжнародні наукові мережі
шляхом приєднання перерізу і бути
вміти працювати над новими темами, які
може не фінансуватися з жодного іншого
джерела
можливості кар'єрного зростання
прийде в дорозі, і це може бути
від діяльності в мережі або від
можливості, які вивчаються
від однолітків
um слідуючи або паралельно до
участь у акції
дію самих поперечних перерізів
забезпечити міжнародну мобільність
можливості, які збільшують
видимість ух певної теми або або
дослідник або дослідницька група, яка
працює над цим
і останнє, але не в останню чергу, якщо хтось має
ємність і
і мужність і
зобов’язання брати участь у відповідь
лідерська діяльність ух
вартості проекту будівництва
тоді це може
принести додаткові адміністративні та
управління
навички та знання людині
і останнє, але не менш важливе
є також повідомлення про бетон
повідомили про вигоду від конструкцій
що показує, що вартість a
попередній портал для подальшого європейського фінансування
і якщо ми обчислимо це в цифрах
на основі даних, які ми маємо
Заявки на горизонт 2020
звітується за закінченою витратою
що ми бачимо, що рівень успіху
повідомили учасники, що
подала заявку на фінансування горизонту 2020 року
е, а раніше ми займалися
витратні дії
і тепер, звичайно, я думаю, що настав момент
дізнатися про витрати
проекти, які коштують
є фінансування
які це проекти і як
діє програма витрат
що таке конструкція витратна дія
мережа мережа дослідників і
новаторів та будь-які інші доп
партнерів, які приєднуються до цієї мережі
тому що
тема, яку потрібно розв’язати
важливий і пов'язаний з um
діяльність
з
учасник
акторська дія базується на меморандумі
розуміння це триває чотири роки
його треба наростити по мінімуму
сім країн повноправних членів
сім країн м від вартості чотирьох
членів
мережі, які вони не фінансують
дослідження, але вони фінансують дослідження
координація
та нарощування потенціалу
і вони мають 500 000 євро як бюджет
протягом чотирьох років їхньої дії
коли ти думаєш про те, як
уявіть собі вартість дії
вартість дії має головну пропозицію не
координатор, у якому немає консорціуму
конструкція та основна пропозиція
це особа, яка подаватиме пропозицію
до
ну до конструкції
від імені мережі пропонентів, що
складається з основної пропозиції та
вторинні пропонатори
і тоді ця мережа може розростатися
коли
пропозиція є
тоді вирішили про фінансування
[Музика]
всі члени прогнозу можуть
також
призначити своїх дослідників до них
дії
але це ще не все
тому що
я маю на увазі дослідників з усіх країн
будь-яку іншу країну, яка не є дорогою
член
може приєднатися до цього, ух, до формування цього
пропозицію в будь-який час на пропозицію
стадії, а також як коли це вже є
забудована
профінансований проект
перехресна дія
вартісні дії працюють з т. зв
мережева діяльність, і це те
заходів, які також фінансуються з
для
з нашого бюджету можуть бути зустрічі
також різні види зустрічей
наради керівництва або робоча група
зборів є навчальні школи
де є стажисти та тренери
запрошений з
країни-учасниці або за її межами
є доповіді на конференціях
організовані третіми сторонами, які могли б бути
також
використовується з метою поширення чи для
інші, і, як я вже згадував, є
мобільність
елемент так званий короткостроковий
обміни для дослідників та новаторів
є також інші можливості для
розповсюдження та комунікаційні проекти
а також публікація гм
передбачається ух під ум
прийнятність кров, вартість або фінансування
діяльність
і як приєднатися до витрат
в основному їх три
можливості це зробити
один - приєднатися до запущеної конструкції
це вже
існуючий
ви можете знайти їх
все на сайті узбережжя
і ви можете просто приєднатися до a
робочої групи шляхом звернення до в
відповідна конструкція
відповідна робоча група
можуть бути й інші способи
приєднатися до витратної акції
тільки до
для коротшого або спеціального
короткостроковим або тимчасовим способом
бути учасником заходу, семінару
бути запрошеним доповідачем приєднатися до a
навчальна школа претендувати на те, щоб бути a
стажист
у навчальному закладі
або до е
мають короткострокову наукову місію
якщо ви в це вірите
якщо ви хочете почати з самого початку
початок, то, звичайно, є
можливість стати членом а
команда пропозицій
через процедуру відкритого виклику, що
вартість - це мати гм
нові пропозиції збираються нові
пропозиції збираються по всьому
рік і е-е-е
одна дата збору буде наступна
в наступному жовтні
е, коли в жовтні 2022 р
де пропозиції подані до часу
збираються оцінені і гм ті
які фінансуються ті, які знайдені
найкращі чи найодруженіші
буде профінансовано
і останнє, але не в останню чергу, ви також можете
стати експертом, щоб оцінити uh
пропозиції, подані до вартості відкритої
дзвонити
але й ум, щоб перевірити, щоб оцінити
поточні дії вартістю та побачити їх
прогрес і їхні досягнення
бути експертом означає це
це повністю онлайн
[Музика]
діяльність і це е
перераховано в ум
з невеликими кількостями
і я думаю, що мій останній слайд саме про це
ну що
як зараз в Україні
конструкції, які ви можете побачити
це, в основному, кількість е
український
учасників поточних витрат
протягом усього горизонту 2020 року
було більш-менш стабільно з цим коротким
невеликий спад
протягом 2019-20
який був
початок
жадаю пандемії тут
гм
який
що зазвичай є
та ж ситуація та сама тенденція
кожна з країн-учасниць
вартість
тож якщо ви бачите, що це приблизно 30 35
відсотків
ух ходових конструкцій з
українські учасники, я б так сказав
є ще багато вартісних заходів
вибігти туди без учасника
з україни
і вони можуть ці витрати дії були б
все ще е
відповідний, доступний і привітний
учасників з вашої країни, але з
звичайно, ви також можете
подумайте, щоб побачити, що таке
наступний
дата збору в
більш-менш рік принесе час
і вже може приєднатися і може спробувати
подивіться, як найкраще сформулювати пропозицію
команди або команди, які пропонують приєднатися
ну
пізно на
для подання
пізніше наступного року
я закінчу тут, дякую
багато для вашої уваги, е, якщо у вас є
будь-які запитання я буду радий відповісти
відповісти, і тепер я припиняю ділитися
дякую Каталін це було дуже дуже
цікавий
і
ми
мав
також запитання чи коментар від
Міністерство науки мотивація, що
Україна повністю приєднається до вартості
тому не могли б ви розповісти нам більше
які ще можливості це дає
україни
якщо порівняти з попереднім
умови, ви можете щось додати
тут
дуже дякую за запитання
ну що я можу сказати, що на даний момент ми
так, тому що статути передбачають
що нові країни можуть запитувати повну
членство до вартості
виконавши певний набір
критерії, які встановлюються
статут і гарна новина полягає в тому, що по
асоціюється з горизонтом Європи
Україна виконала всі критерії
які передбачені в минулому
статут асоціації і ми
зараз ведуться переговори або
обговорюємо з міністерством, яке є
можливих представників с
міністерство
ну як і коли
Україна подасть свій запит до
стати повноправним членом на вартість
і це прохання буде
отримано та опрацьовано за вартістю
капітал
в
вищих посадових осіб
прийняти своє рішення
якщо рішення позитивне і
група стає повним числом, щоб коштувати тоді
звичайно статус
дослідників з України зміниться
і тоді ця презентація стане
застаріло, але сьогодні це те
презентація, яка все ще переважає
і тоді я буду я думаю, що буде
дуже вигідно організувати ще один захід
там пояснити
детально основні зміни
дуже скоро зміни будуть гм
звичайно, що
як повноправний член України, будь-хто з
Україна матиме право запропонувати a
будівництво так ви дослідники з
країна може стати головними пропонентами
і
вони повинні потім зібрати
пропонуюча мережа
і раптом вони можуть подати
пропозиції
від їхнього імені від імені цього
пропозиція мережі як основна пропозиція
ще одна зміна, в яку я вірю
значний
є як повноправний член Україна
має право приймати та організовувати будь-які витрати
діяльність
що узгоджується в будь-якій конструкції, що
погоджується керуючим комітетом
виявлення
тож у вас буде набагато більше гнучкості
запросити колег із с
будівництво і
використання
всі зручності
що у вас є
та організуйте діяльність, яку ви
відчувати себе важливим
в україні
дуже дякую це було дуже
цікавий і забезпечує укр
дослідники
з можливістю ближче
співпрацю для інструментів для цього
і я цілком впевнений, що вони скористаються
це повністю, навіть якщо
Україна не є повноправним членом, але ми бачимо
згідно зі статистикою
наскільки активні українські дослідники
використовуючи ці можливості, дякую
багато для цієї презентації
а зараз я хотів би сказати
що це не єдина програма
над яким працює міністерство
багато з вас чули про еврику
програма
і
дослідників і вчених і
нею користуються новатори
і є нові ініціативи
є нові
події в європейському союзі та i
хотів би надати слово
програмний координатор кластерної області
у програмі «Еврика» Себастьян Альброн
він розповість вам більше про оновлену
програма кластерів уреки і
я б хотів
попросіть наших техніків перевірити, чи є
звук
доброго дня, себастьян
Ви можете почути нас
доброго дня
ми дуже чекаємо на вас
презентація
і почути більше про
можливості програми еврика
будь ласка, підлога ваша
дуже дякую, гм як
вступ я хотів би
привітати міністерство освіти
та науки україни за орган
цей день досліджень та інновацій
гм, я думаю, що інтеграція в
Європейський дослідницький простір є дуже
справді важлива тема
і для багатьох країн
е, інновації мають нові кордони, як ми говоримо
тут у мережі eureka так я дуже
багато на це сподіваюся
ця конкретна сесія з різних
європейські програми та дослідження
фреймворки просвітлять
українська аудиторія сьогодні і
сприяють активізації участі
учасники України в майбутньому
як сказано, зараз я вам покажу
програма ecp кластери еврика
програма
котрий
звісно, ​​це одна з програм еврики
Тож, по-перше, що таке еврика, я знаю
деякі з вас більше знайомі, ніж
інші, але я думаю, що це може бути важливо
щоб дати um встановити сцену там і
надати глобальний образ
eureka – це міжнародна мережа
понад 45 країн, у тому числі також
країни за межами європи
наприклад, Канада, Сінгапур, Південна Африка
і південна корея
це сьогодні найбільша у світі публіка
мережа міжнародного співробітництва в
бізнес-дослідження розвитку та
інновації
наша співпраця з однодумцями
країни
не в змозі протистояти глобальним викликам і
для підвищення конкурентоспроможності
підприємства-учасники
і ми вважаємо, що такі глобальні
співпраця сприятиме будівництву
скажімо, стійкі ланцюги поставок у
майбутнє
дуже коротко існує чотири загальних
цілі, спільні для всіх в евріці
програми, які ви можете побачити на слайді
там
надання доступу до державного фінансування
чому, тому що ми віримо, що з доступом
на національне державне фінансування
ваше амбітне міжнародне дослідження
проекти стають досяжними і тому відтоді
1985 еврика дала більше 50
мільярдів на підтримку організацій та до
підтримати успіх більше ніж 7
науково-дослідницькі проекти
наша друга мета — їздити
міжнародне співробітництво
ми віримо, що евріка — гарне місце
для організації
для організацій, яких вибачте
перша хороша міжнародна співпраця
досвід
і програми еврики насправді
заохочувати власників проектів до розробки нового
дослідження та розробки та бізнес
відносини на міжнародному рівні
є висока якість інновацій в
мережі існують комбіновані експертизи
та обміну знаннями та в
закінчиться це
учасники мають високі шанси на проект
успіх
посилення експансії на нові ринки, як i
сказав, що в складі 45 країн
мережа евріка
і
ці різні програми, на яких вони зосереджені
дослідження та розробки близьких до с
ринку
продукти, процеси та послуги тощо
це полегшує учасникам
досліджувати нові ринки, якщо вони приєднаються до
різні програми можуть бути в Європі можуть
бути зовні
не в останню чергу персональні поради
це важлива інформація, я думаю
можливо, ми матимемо коментарі з цього приводу
питання потім
у всіх 45 країнах еврики, які я хотів би
наполягати на тому, що існують національні
проекти називають підлітками, які мають а
великий досвід підтримки досліджень
і проекти розвитку і
співпрацювати з партнерами навколо
світу і вони можуть надати укр
аудиторії та укр
власники проекту з культурним контекстом на
різні локальні програми
мову
вони можуть направити вас до потрібної програми
правильних партнерів і допоможе знайти
правильний додаток, як ніби я ні
помилково за україну це
міністерство освіти і науки, яке
є відповідальною національною установою
для всіх програм Eureka
і
тепер що таке програма ecp
тому ecp є довгостроковим
підтримка міжурядової ініціативи
важливі дослідження та розробки
спільноти навколо стратегічних тем
Метою цього ecp є створення вартості
до обох галузей
та суспільства в
країни-учасниці еврики
і для досягнення цієї загальної мети
і для створення економічної сили ecp
працює в тісній співпраці з
органи державної влади
також забезпечення міцного узгодження з
це їхні національні пріоритети
щось дуже унікальне в евриці
програма вирівнювання між
загальної програми та нац
пріоритети, щоб це було безпрограшним
ситуація
перейти до наступного слайду, який я хотів би
щоб підкреслити зараз певний ключ
специфіки
програми ecp, я думаю, це допоможе
це
аудиторії та українського потенціалу
учасників
щоб краще зрозуміти
як ecp відрізняється від інших
національні та міжнародні дослідження та
програми розвитку та інновацій
так спочатку
широкі rdni теми і сильні
екосистеми
прямо зараз ecp охоплює
п'ять
громади п'ять кластерів
на якому я буду трішки наполягати
потім, але я можу назвати їх
один із комунікацій наступного покоління
одна з них стосується низьковуглецевих енергетичних технологій
один на інновації програмного забезпечення, один на
виготовлення і виробництво
технології
і один на електронних компонентах і
системи
протягом багатьох років ці добре пов’язані
громади мають сильний інтерес
у відповідному домені та вони
об’єднати кваліфікованих спеціалістів і
експертів
щоб охопити весь їхній ланцюжок вартості
відповідний домен
спільна точка всіх цих
спільнот або кластерів полягає в тому, що вони
зближувати
smes
великі галузі промисловості великі організації
також дослідження та технології
організації університетів і наук
і ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
мають потенціал
українські учасники цих
різні спільноти приносять свої
знання та їхні ідеї
гм
що робить кластерну програму специфічною
також є те, що мова йде не тільки про
підтримуючи ці п’ять громад
також про спільну діяльність і
стратегії
і
це забезпечується багатонаціональним і
багатопрофільна
підхід програми
і яскравий приклад цього
співробітництво між цими громадами
це те, що ми називаємо спільною кластерною школою
так
ми запускаємо зараз з 2021 року
спільний хід між кластерами
з думкою, що
змішування спільнот і створення їх
співпраця допоможе розробити нові
продукти, нові послуги та нові процеси
промислово керований і заснований на
міждисциплінарні інновації
ринковий підхід знизу вгору
я знаю, що це може трохи звучати
варвар, але ідея досить проста
полягає в тому, що підхід через
кластерів є заохочення промисловості до
спрямовувати напрям дослідження, але в а
підхід знизу вгору
ідея полягає в тому, щоб бути близько до ринку
з темами дослідження та відповідати
бізнес і потреби клієнтів
так
через свої автомобільні системи існуючі
кластери, до яких вони мають доступ
розвідки клієнтів, і вони добре знають
ринку, тому коли ви берете участь у
ці програми у вас є великий шанс
комерційного успіху згодом
широкий географічний охоплення та гнучкість
я вже говорив про це
45 країн еврики
і виходячи з національних пріоритетів ми
є гнучкими, ми можемо запускати ініціативи
якщо підтримується
деякі конкретні країни на спільній
topic, і це створює змінну
геометрія ініціатив або або спільна
зателефонує потім, це можливо
якщо країни візьмуть участь у
мережі
легкий доступ для sme
хм, я хотів би підкреслити цей момент
тому що я вважаю, що це дуже важливо
одна з кластерних спільнот і це
також, можливо, відрізняється від інших програм
вони роблять це дуже легко для smes
брати участь і співпрацювати з великими
компаній кластера евріка
парасолька
і ми вважаємо, що smes однаково
важливі, як і будь-який інший партнер, і вони
представляють між 40 і 50 з
учасники проекту в кластерах
проект
ми вважаємо, що ці smes сприяють
нестандартне мислення до спритності
до гнучкості
і це також для них і для вас
хороша можливість зв'язатися
великі організації, які будуть
недоступні в іншому випадку, а також доступ
і впливати на нові ринки
на міжнародному рівні
тісна співпраця з громадськістю
влади, я торкнувся цього елемента
перед
але я хотів би наполягати і на цьому
від створення ідеї до проекту
подання
uh ecp гарантує, що проекти
профінансовані дуже відповідають
національні пріоритети з точки зору досліджень
та інновації
щоб зрештою проект профінансували
також сприяє
висока рентабельність інвестицій для
національний
залучених органів йдеться про підтримку
учасникам йдеться про підтримку
також національні органи влади
ефективність ecp для дзвінків і проектів
управління, в яке я вступати не збираюся
всі деталі, але тільки щоб повідомити вам
що для всіх потенційних учасників
дослідницькі організації університетів МСП
тощо
основний менеджмент і проект
управління робить це досить простим для вас
приєднуватися і брати участь і
сприяти
під час організації дзвінків
наприклад, брокерські події ми
організувати семінари для клієнтів, які ми організували
також вебінари з нац
влади
і ми дійсно підтримуємо і проект
наказує до
підготувати хороші та якісні пропозиції
відповідно до цілей
програми
Управління проектами - це та ж ідея, що і ми
є гнучкими, наприклад, якщо під час
проект
ваш
цілі також можуть трохи відрізнятися
утримання
в
важливо дотримуватися змін
середовища
дослідження та розвиток
ми також можемо підтримувати ці модифікації
проекту ми можемо змінити деякі з
Учасники проектів ми дуже
гнучкі за умови загальної мети
залишається
і останнє, але не в останню чергу, високий вплив для
учасників проекту
хм і високий ефект від участі
країн так для учасників проекту
і
завдяки дуже підтримці
підхід і гнучкий підхід
і більшість компаній-учасниць
а також інше
тип зацікавлених сторін, які я назвав
раніше вони принесли користь
від короткого часу доступу до ринку
і протягом наступних двох років вони мають
багато шансів комерціалізувати їх
демонстратори своїх прототипів і до
мати хорошу віддачу від інвестицій
тому країни також виграють
від цього збільшився річний оборот з
зацікавлені сторони та
зростання зайнятості
так що для країн це також дуже
важливо, тому що вони досягають високого
економічна та соціальна віддача від їх
громадський
інвестиції
підтримуючи їх дослідження
пріоритети розвитку та інновацій
тож це був лише невеликий огляд
різних характеристик цього нового
Програма кластерів eureka
Гадаю, у нас залишилося кілька хвилин
не вдаючись у всі деталі, але
Ви можете побачити форму і структуру
цієї нової програми кластерів Eureka
який є інструментом, що об’єднує
національні промислові стратегії разом
з національним фінансуванням
підтримуючий
дослідницькі ініціативи
з одного боку видно, що у вас є
комітет державної влади з інших
у вас є комітет кластерів
промисловості, і вони спільно працюють
разом
разом із центральним координуючим
функціонувати із загальною метою
забезпечити узгодженість та якість проектів
ви також можете побачити п'ять існуючих
спільноти або кластери
кельтський європейський itr smart і xccs котрий
всі вони спеціалізуються на своєму
домену
я ще раз хотів би там згадати
ecp характеризується високим
гнучкість у тому, як це стосується
цих нових технологічних областях, а також шляхом
динамічне державно-приватне співробітництво
добре, тож переходимо до наступного слайда
п'ять кластерів на даний момент, так що ви
можна побачити імена
гм
якщо є якісь запитання чи якісь конкретні питання
інтерес з боку української аудиторії до
брехуни з одним певним кластером
потім, будь ласка, не соромтеся
зв'яжіться зі мною, і я зв'яжу з вами
з відповідним
обслуговування
тож у нас є кельтський, який є наступним
створення безпечних комунікацій
для людей, орієнтованих на довіру та
стійке цифрове суспільство, тому все
ic пов’язані питання 5g тощо
низьковуглецевих енергетичних технологій є euroja
і всі теми відновлюваних джерел та
зелені теми
це зосередження на інноваціях програмного забезпечення
smart — це нова кластерна адресація
виготовлення і виробництво
технології
а xecs працює над електронним
компонентів і систем також дуже
великий кластер
щоб завершити презентацію я б
люблять підкреслювати постійну можливість
Я говорив про п’ять існуючих
кластери у своїх громадах, але є
є також можливості для укр
зацікавлені сторони, які будуть залучені до спільної
діяльність
і це гарний приклад суглоба
кластери називають так званими загальними
різні кластери
зараз ми над цим працюємо з
п'ять кластерів і разом з більше
ми зараз підтримуємо більше 10 країн
15 країн підтримки та підтримки
подзвоніть майбутній бюджет, і вони будуть
мати можливість потім, коли
у лютому розпочинається конкурс на фінансування
їхніх учасників національного проекту
так, я хотів би подякувати вам за ваш
увагу
буду дуже радий відповісти на будь-яке
питання, яке може виникнути, дякую
дякую, Себастьян, це було дуже-дуже
цікаво і наскільки я зрозумів
з вашої презентації укр
учасники також можуть взяти в них участь
будь ласка, ініціативи
скажи нам
як
вони можуть
робити те, що вони повинні робити це
що він повинен зробити для цього, дякую
дякую дякую за запитання
це дуже гарне питання і
відповідь - так, хм, Україна - еврика
член, думаю, з 2006 року
і українські партнери проекту дуже
вітаємо в програмі кластерів
як в поодиноких кластерах, так і в
спільна діяльність між кластерами
Україна вже брала участь
різні програми еврики в минулому
не тільки кластери
і якщо я правильно пам'ятаю, у вас є
дослідження національних університетів
інститути та деякі компанії вже
залучений
тож тепер як взяти участь
взяти участь в українському проекті
учасники вони повинні дотримуватися
Критерії прийнятності еврики, які є
загальний для всіх країн еврики, усі 45
країни
і якщо вони хочуть отримати нац
фінансування, яким вони також повинні відповідати
національні правила фінансування своїх національних
програма досліджень та інновацій
так, це була б моя відповідь
дуже дякую, так що в принципі
відповів на моє друге запитання, що таке
критерії прийнятності для ecp
пропозиції
і, можливо, ви можете додати щось інше
друге питання
о, вибач, я не зовсім зрозумів
так що я мав на увазі
проекти еврики знаходяться внизу а
проекту, щоб українські учасники могли
також
гм приєднатися до них так друге питання що
є критеріями прийнятності для ecp
пропозиції, на які ви вже відповіли
але, можливо, ви можете додати щось інше
дуже дякую за це додаткове
Питання, я думаю, дуже важливе
також, і я хотів би зробити a
там попереднє зауваження
знати про право на еврику
критерії та правила фінансування
міжнародний
країна
я б рекомендував яскраво рекомендую
Потенціал українських учасників проекту
учасників до брехунів з нац
фінансове агентство, яке є міністерством
освіти
та науки україни та до контакту
зокрема національний проект
координатор
зараз, взагалі кажучи, є
два
суворі критерії прийнятності для
кластерні пропозиції
тільки два
перший — це консорціум
потрібно мати принаймні
двох незалежних партнерів
походить із двох різних еврик
країн, наприклад, це може бути
науково-дослідний інститут або університет або
компанія з україни лізинг с
інший з іншої країни і все
має право
Другий критерій - це проект
слід
користь для всіх залучених партнерів у
добре збалансований консорціум
що це означає, що ні
одна організація чи країна може
становить понад 75
70 на жаль відсотків від загального бюджету
тож ви бачите два основних критерії
це досить гнучка програма, її легко зробити
доступ і є невелика паперова робота
гм, але тоді це може трохи відхилитися
біт залежно від дзвінків залежно від
кластерна специфіка і там
можуть бути додаткові критерії
гм, але це дві основні
критерії вулиці
так
дякую дуже дякую
це добре, що ми змогли
розкажіть більше про цей чудовий засіб
eureka, і я думаю, що це принесе більше
увагу наукової спільноти
і ми побачимо Україну в числі одного з них
найбільш активні країни, які не тільки
проводить дослідження, але й реалізовувати
їм в інноваціях велике спасибі
sebastian і тепер ми продовжуємо нашу
наступний доповідач
і я хотів би сказати, що так
наук
і
дослідження – це головне
дослідники повинні турбуватися про але
без реалізації цих результатів
також важливо досягти економічних
зростання і
це питання дуже важливе для України
і питання таке
як наука має працювати з бізнесом
як наука повинна працювати з інноваціями
як все це реалізувати
і гм
це питання не тільки для України
це питання для всього
світ
і скельні знаряддя
що
гм
може бути менш відомим в Україні, але
Україна може приєднатися до них, тому я
хотів би запросити нашого наступного спікера
Діана Мордекова
а Діана є менеджером
стратегічний
проекти Європейського інституту для
інновацій і технологій і вона
розповість нам про можливості
це гм
на цю тему, тому ми також шукаємо
з нетерпінням чекаю цього
велике дякую, тіана, підлога є
твій
ласкаво просимо
тому доброго ранку всім і привіт
принаймні з Будапешта
звати діана модракова і я
Офіцер з підтримки проектів стратегії в
європейський інститут
інновацій і технологій також відомі
як eit
сьогодні я покажу вам, як
ми заохочуємо інноваційний талант
і потужність європи
і я торкнуся нашої стратегії і
наші цілі наша місія та амбіції та
наші досягнення наразі
eit відіграє ключову роль у підвищенні
інновації в Європі з метою
розв’язати постбажану кризу, а також
для забезпечення зеленого та стійкого
майбутнє
eit має стати ще сильнішим
протягом найближчих років з європейським
комісія запропонувала валун мандат
та бюджет для eit як частину
програма «Новий горизонт Європи».
Майбутнє Європи залежить від інновацій ми
потрібно повернути
нові продукти та послуги
на ринок, щоб залишатися глобальними
конкурентоспроможний, і саме тому eit був
створений ще в 2008 році для боротьби з європейськими
слабкості для інновацій і допомагають їм
конкурувати
eit також був налаштований на водіння
інновації вперед це означає створення
правильне середовище для європейців
сприяння інноваторам та підприємцям
дослідження, орієнтоване на громадян та допомога ЄС
країни більше вкладають у свої
інноваційні можливості
ми знаємо, що для того, щоб робити інновації
працювати
освіта дослідження та підприємництво
потрібно зібратися
протягом багатьох років eit міцно
зарекомендував себе як головний в Європі
інструмент для просування трьох
потоки та працюють у всьому
інноваційний ланцюг створення вартості від студента до
підприємець від ідеї до продукту
лабораторії замовнику
вся діяльність EIT заснована
навколо
наша унікальна інноваційна модель
так зване трикутне інтегрування
вибачте так званий трикутник знань
інтеграція, яка поєднує три ключ
бізнес-дослідження інгредієнтів і
освіти
навколо цього ми будуємо екосистему
інноваційні гравці, які беруть участь у
діяльність у всіх eit
спільноти від венчурних капіталістів до
регіональна влада споживачам тощо
як ви можете бачити на слайді
eit наразі включає вісім
спільноти знань та інновацій
також відомий як удари ногами для короткого
беруть на себе найбільше суспільство
виклики, які стоять перед Європою сьогодні та
включають цифровізацію зміни клімату
відновлювані джерела енергії для здоров'я сировини
харчування розумне виробництво та міські
мобільність
в наступному році тільки близько
куточок у 2022 році на громаді буде
вітаючи новий удар eit uh культура та
творчість, яка підтримає
культури та творчості та
галузей шляхом підключення інновацій
ланцюги створення вартості на місцевому регіональному рівні
регіонам допомоги на національному рівні та на рівні ЄС
впроваджувати інновації та збільшувати їх
конкурентоспроможність шляхом руйнування
перешкоди для інновацій у різних галузях
і дисципліни, що стимулюють нові підприємства
прискорення нових технологій і
сприяння цифровій трансформації
і шляхом розширення можливостей наступного покоління
культури творчих новаторів і
оснащення їх необхідним
підприємницькі навички
трохи пізніше в 2026 році IT-спільнота
вітатиме 10-й удар по воді
який буде підтримувати водний морен і
мартинські сектори та екосистеми з
зосередитися на посухі дефіциту води та
повені
морська та прісноводна екосистема
деградація і кругова і
стійка блакитна економіка
Horizon Europe керуватиме майбутнім
європейські дослідження та інновації це
дає чудову можливість
покращувати нашу роботу та співпрацювати
європа
програми ЄС, зберігаючи наші
екосистемна модель, яка довела
досі служити європейським інноваціям
добре поки що
розміщений у стовпі 3 горизонту Європи
eit і його удари будуть ключовими
гравців у рамках програми через
їх міждисциплінарний підхід
у нас бюджет приблизно 3
млрд євро, що на 25 більше
до попереднього періоду фінансування, який
дасть нам можливість розвиватися
реалізувати наші амбіційні амбіції
цілі, довірені нам згідно з
горизонт європи
наші удари допомагають новаторам перетворити їх
ідеї в передові продукти
послуги та роботи, якими вони це займаються
виховання наступного покоління
підприємців через освіт
програми, що поєднують як технічні, так і
підприємницькі навички
підживлюючи підприємства через бізнес
послуги створення та прискорення та
шляхом надання розумних рішень для
найбільші виклики Європи
підтримка інноваційних досліджень
проекти
також регіональна інноваційна схема eit
відомий як ризик eit
допомагає та пропонує індивідуальну підтримку
країни та регіони, які є
вважаються скромними або поміркованими новаторами
відповідно до європейських інновацій
табло та включати країни-члени ЄС
і найвіддаленіші регіони, а також
прийнятний горизонт Європа пов’язана
країни
на 2021-2027 рр. ризик eit став
розширений і обов'язковий і невід'ємний
частина стратегій eit кидає за допомогою an
бюджет збільшився на 15
всіх грантів eit
метою є покращення потенціалу
місцева екосистема підтримує
цілі залучення нових партнерів
створити нові важелі eit hubs
додаткове державне та приватне фінансування як
а також міцність зміцнювати зв'язки з
стратегії розумної спеціалізації
ми також нещодавно запустили
[Музика]
нова ініціатива eit hei, про яку йдеться
для підвищення підприємницької та
інноваційний потенціал вищ
заклади освіти
Ой, вибачте
другий
завдяки цій ініціативі eit буде
підтримка вищих навчальних закладів с
фінансування експертизи та навчання
розвивати господарську діяльність і так само
eit risk ініціатива eith hei була
призначений для початку діяльності в
країни з нижчим рівнем інновацій
потужності
було запущено перше пілотне видання
цього року в травні 2021 і 24 травня
були відібрані проекти
а другий і я вірю досі
активний дзвінок опубліковано 18 числа
листопад 2021 року вибере ще 40
проекти для
пілотний етап
за останнє десятиліття ми досягли a
лот ми підтримали понад 3 800
підприємства створили понад 1400 нових продуктів
та послуги
створив понад 13 000 робочих місць і допоміг
стартапи залучають понад 3,9 млрд євро
у нас також є зовнішні інвестиції
закінчив понад 3800 магістрів і кандидатів наук
студентів через eit
лейбл програм і зареєструвалися тисячі
більше в наших навчальних програмах
кілька стартапів, які підтримуються
вони обернулися великим успіхом
історії досягнення статусу єдинорога з
оцінка та інвестиції понад 1
мільярд євро
таких як lillium aviation за підтримки
ait кліматичний удар
який розробляється першим у світі
повністю електричний вертикальний зліт і
посадковий реактивний літак
Northwalt підтримується
енергія, яка розвиває світ
найзеленіші літій-іонні акумулятори
комаха підтримується також eit клімату
удар і розвиток інновацій до
агрохарчової та біотехнологічної промисловості та більшість
останнім часом смугляве здоров'я підтримали
eit health та пропонує віртуальну допомогу
хворих на мск
біль
гм
більше інформації про можливості
і
інформацію про те, що і як ми робимо
його можна знайти на нашому сайті
eit.europe.eu
і ми вітаємо вас також приєднатися до нас
наш linkedin у наших соціальних мережах
канали до
слідкуйте за новинами і гм
і мати можливість отримати останні
я дякую за увагу
дуже дякую, Діана, це було дуже
цікаво і дуже важливо і я
хотів би сказати, що Україна має
реформується не тільки в галузі науки
та освіти
але також у нас була інша реформа
реформа децентралізації
і багато регіонів України
думають про розумних
питання спеціалізації
і проблеми, які ви піднімаєте
в плані створення інноваційних
екосистема всередині
розумна спеціалізація регіону с
країна і так далі
але все ж
ряд українських дослідників, які
є
хто приєднується до цих проектів, чи не вони
ця цифра невелика, тому питання таке
що можна зробити, щоб мотивувати
дослідники
для поглиблення співпраці
я маю на увазі ці ваші проекти
дослідники з укр
так, це правда, на жаль
гм участь участь
України була дуже обмеженою
але потенціал, безперечно, є
збільшити це і було
нові інструменти, створені для цього конкретного
призначення, наприклад, новоствореного
ncp мережа, а також
hei ініціатива, яку я обговорював
що може краще допомогти eit залучитися
з україною
і ми також бачимо підвищений інтерес
з боку ударів ногами і прикладом
це, наприклад, міська мобільність
яка веде безперервні переговори з
міністерство освіти і науки с
україни
аналізуючи, як і коли це найкраще
спілкуватися з українською українською
інновація в результаті
eit також планує eit
інформаційний захід в україні в
на початку або на початку 2022 р
ми сподіваємося створити таку співпрацю
система також
не забудемо про це згадати
Україна підписала асоціацію
угоду і, таким чином, має право приймати
участь у посилених регіональних інноваціях
схема своєї діяльності та її
можливості
і їх можна знайти на нашому сайті
які також зацікавлені сторони можуть знайти
контакти з окремою особою eit chris
там менеджери
і можете вільно звернутися, щоб знайти
подальші можливості, які є
доступні під рукою або майбутні, які є
вже запланований і поданий затверджений
і торкнутися цих розумних
стратегії спеціалізації
eitrios має підхід, заснований на розміщенні
для створення кращого зв’язку
до цих стратегій s3
які можуть бути корисними, тому що ми
знати, що була активна
реалізація цих стратегій
в регіонах по україні
дуже дякую за відповідь дякую
вам дуже за вашу презентацію
я думаю, що це приверне більше
зверніть увагу на проекти, які ви
організація пропонує
а також це допоможе створити це
інноваційна екосистема, до якої Україна
також буде частиною великої подяки
я сподіваюся
гм
що заплановано на 2022 рік
буде ще активніше і буде
привертають до них ще більше уваги
проекти дуже дякую
я хотів би сказати
що ми почули багато цікавого
речі про новий проект про
нові можливості, і ми почули a
багато про зміни
в європейському
Союзу та в Європейській комісії
тому нові перспективи
розвиток європейського дослідницького простору
і за ним слідує Україна
і у нас наступне
гм
[Музика]
наступна сесія о 12:20, а зараз у нас
невелика перерва
ті з вас, хто є серед глядачів
з нами ви можете приєднатися до нашої маленької кави
перерва
і всі онлайн-глядачі
будь ласка, чудово відпочивайте та приєднуйтесь
через 20-30 хвилин дуже дякую
продовжимо через півгодини
доброго дня продовжуємо наше дослідження
та День інновацій в Україні
організовано міністерством
освіти і науки україни і нині
ми хочемо поговорити про дуже важливе
аспект
що
є
актуальний для будь-якого дослідника
Україна дуже відома своїми дослідженнями
потенціал і дослідники
але
кращий дослідник ще вимагає
обладнання
з яким він чи вона може зробити своє
власне дослідження
то чим займається міністерство
в
розвивається
дослідницька інфраструктура дуже
важливо, і я думаю, що ми навчимося
детальніше про досягнення в найближчому
хм в останні роки, тому зараз
я хотів би надати слово
до пані ірини пролозки вона держава
експерт експертної групи
з питань розвитку науки
міністерство науки і освіти с
Україна, і вона розповість нам більше
на цю тему, Mr inum
доброго дня дуже дякую за
можливість зробити це
презентація, яку я хотів би представити
інноваційний механізм державної політики
на розвиток дослідження
інфраструктури
почну з питань
розвитку наукових досліджень
інфраструктури
питання залишилися для низки
років
і основні питання
ну той факт, що гм
гм
так
незадовільні матеріально-технічні
умовою основою наук
установи та вільні економічні зони
відсутність гідних умов праці та
обмежені комфортні робочі приміщення
придатність до використання коштів спеціальної держави
фонд різниці між потребами
реальний сектор економіки і
можливості існуючих дослідницьких проблем
забезпечення технічного та інженерного забезпечення
персонал
і для вирішення цих питань
міністерство проводить свою політику
створення важливих документів, але спочатку
з всіх
я б хотів
до
[Музика]
розповісти вам більше про
терміни
існуючу дослідницьку інфраструктуру
в законодавстві так що таке дослідження
інфраструктура це набір інструментів
ресурс і супутні послуги, якими користуються
наукове співтовариство провести
дослідження на найвищому рівні висвітлення
Найбільш важливим
об'єкти наукового обладнання та
засоби або набори пристроїв ресурси
на основі архівів колекцій знань
депозитарії або наук
на основі інфраструктури баз даних
комунікаційні технології комп'ютер
програмне забезпечення та мережеві комунікації та
інші унікальні споруди
тож ви пам’ятаєте, що ми над цим працювали
дуже важливий документ
і
починаємо
з гм
тому в основному ми зосереджуємось на факті
що гм
ми
наближення до українського законодавства
законодавство ЄС так
давайте розглянемо ключові відмінності
між
в цей термін між законодавством ЄС
і українське законодавство, перш за все
всі
дослідницька інфраструктура є ум
є генералом
номер
інструментів і в ЄС вони можуть бути
локально
локальний віртуальний або розділений
і
ці дослідники можуть бути
це частина міжнародних мереж
до ЄС і до України
йде
2015 року було прийнято рішення про те, що
держава
дослідницькі інфраструктури мають бути
запроваджено і законодавство ЄС
не має його
і це
об'єднання гм
установ
що
йдеться про оптимальне використання його ресурсів
бази даних тощо та координація
його ефективне використання для проведення
наукові дослідження
ми розуміємо
що ці
два
концепції
створити певне непорозуміння
і в складі укр
законодавство питання в тому, як ух
інфраструктура ЄС має відповідати
український, тому ми
почав використовувати
з національною радою ум
з питань техніки
і ми почали працювати над змінами
законодавство
на
дослідницька інфраструктура
ця справа мала бути першою
але в 2020 році президент україни
прийняв указ
номер
і
цей ступінь сказав це
має бути програма для
розвиток дослідження
інфраструктури та як частина цього
ступеня міністерство розпочало роботу над а
дуже важливий стратегічний документ
до 2026 року
то чому дослідницькі інфраструктури, а ні
науково-дослідницькі інфраструктури
ми спробували ввести цей термін під цю назву
відповідно до
європейське законодавство і
національна дорожня карта розвитку с
гм
слід було розгорнути дослідження
і наші
У документі зазначено, що це державна програма
і мета
цієї державної програми йдеться про створення
юридичні та інші умови для того, щоб
розвивати дослідницьку інфраструктуру для
підвищення його конкурентоспроможності і в
наказати
розширити співпрацю та доступ до
науковців до
гм
просунутий
дослідницькі структури європ
союз
ступінь 322
прийняла це і на сьогоднішній день
над цим працює міністерство науки
на
питання держави
програма з розвитку дослід
інфраструктури ключові етапи
знаходяться на слайді
це гм
тож це штати посилюють
механізм державної підтримки прав
форми дослідницької інфраструктури
ідентифікація
інвентаризація систематизація
інфраструктури дослідницької інфраструктури
три
надання
забезпечення розвитку наук
та виконання порядку денного
створення списку досліджень
інфраструктури та номер чотири
розвиток фінансових інструментів, пов'язаних
до цього і створення номер п’ять
міжнародний
зв'язки з європейськими дослідженнями
інфраструктури ми будемо говорити про них
пізніше, тому в рамках цієї програми там
є ключовими принципами роботи
з ними відкрите дослідження
інфраструктури, тож вони такі
принципи є
як тоді отримати доступ
співавторство
правовий відп
відповідальність
потім
фінансові питання, а потім етична поведінка
недискримінації
усунення
бюрократії
посібник для кінцевого користувача та
управління даними дослідження так все
цього потрібно зробити, щоб бути
комплектувати відповідно до ЄС
Законодавство також ми зосередилися на
парадигми відкритої науки ми будемо говорити
докладніше про це пізніше, тепер я хотів би
сказати, що це загальний доступ
наукові дані
гм, що отримано за рахунок
державний кошт
можливість доступу і друге
використовувати для всіх
з усіх наукових
дані
без обмежень кордонами чи
напрямки роботи і номер три
рівнів
можливості та правила участі
дослідників, які зараз говорять про
принципи розвитку дослід
інфраструктури їх декілька
так
концентрація дослідницької інфраструктури
а людські дослідження здійснюються наукою
відповідно до викликів суспільства тоді
реалізація принципів відкритості
наука тоді
збереження академічного самоврядування
як базові цінності під час політики
виконання відповідно до держ
пріоритети наступної властивості
дослідження стану оптимізації
інфраструктуру виключно для забезпечення
цілі розвитку наукової сфери
а потім ізоляція керівництва
функції ух щодо власності та
визначення наукових пріоритетів і
діяльності дуже дякую, що я
хотів би сказати те, що ми чули
біля
перша частина нашої дискусії
представники європ
комісія
говорили про відкриту науку і ми
бачу, що Україна — це гм
на тому ж рівні
і ми на одному рівні з
європейської спільноти, і ми можемо
кажуть, що укр
інфраструктура вже інтегрована
цьому контексті, тому проблеми, які ви
піднятий
що стосується розвитку досліджень
інфраструктури
гм
це
ми можемо говорити про фінансування тому
питання таке
програму, яку ви згадали
робить
це означає
фінансування або які фінансові інструменти
доступні в рамках цієї програми anselm
дуже дякую за це питання
дуже важливо
і станом на сьогодні міністерство с
освіта і наука ведуть переговори
з міністерством фінансів і ми бачимо
що є ключовий гравець, який
визначає пріоритети, які розподіляє
гроші
і
ми від імені нашого міністерства робимо
всі зусилля, щоб схвалити
всі додаткові гроші на цю потребу
з метою розвитку дослідження
інфраструктури
тому я вірю
що найближчим часом
ми почуємо
більше про
міністерство фінансів ми послухаємо
що вони мають сказати
Дякую
дякую, я думаю, що наше
головна мета - досягти кращих результатів
для розвитку
дослідницької інфраструктури та
вчені та дослідники намагатимуться
підтримую вас у служінні, дякую
багато за всю важку роботу, яку ви виконуєте
дякую, пані Ірина і зараз
я хотів би надати слово
до нашого спікера
з європейського
консорціум
дослідницька інфраструктура добре
вдень
гм
містер Орнела Джакомо
ну добрий день
ми бачимо
я б хотів
представити гм
я хотів би представити
заступник виконавчого директора Ерік і
будь ласка, розкажіть нам більше про
інтеграція цієї організації
я думаю, що в україні
ваша організація менш відома, але
у світі зараз досить добре
будь ласка
гм, міс Орнела, розкажи нам більше про
вашої презентації ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
щоб почути те, що ти маєш сказати
дуже дякую, що запросили нас
цей дуже важливий день і
вітаю україну всіх
прогрес, який вони досягають у
інтеграція в європейські дослідження
площа
якщо
Я можу поділитися своїми слайдами так, дякую
гм
Ну
за межі статики, то я потраплю
конкретна точка cerric але beyonce
ну
дослідницькі інфраструктури мають основ
роль в інтеграції uh
наукової інтеграції україни від
точку зору користувачів, яку ми називаємо
користувачів, дослідників, які фактично використовують
це дослідницька інфраструктура
щось у нас є
бачив, і я розповім про це пізніше
але
зазвичай, коли ви співпрацюєте з a
дослідницька інфраструктура в європейській
рівень або міжнародний рівень є a
негайне розширення бази використання в
україни
тому що
дослідницькі інфраструктури багато інвестують
стають відомими, тому є
інформаційні дні навчання специфічні
тренінги на інструментах на що можна
проводити з цими дослідженнями
інфраструктури, а також підтримка
підготовка пропозицій цих досліджень
інфраструктури зазвичай відкриті для
всі, крім процесу доступу до них
потрібна програма, а потім там
це вибір, тому якщо додаток є
не добре написана багато разів наука
відмінно, але додаток ні
добре написано, тому цей крок складний
і якщо ви натомість вирішите відкрити
через вашу дослідницьку інфраструктуру
співпраця з європейським консорціумом
або інший
міжнародна інфраструктура
через відкритий доступ те, що ви отримаєте
кінець – це краще використовувати ваш локальний
інфраструктури
більшість
дослідницькі інфраструктури дотримуються
принцип відкритого доступу т. вибір
заснований тільки на якості, і це дозволяє
отримати
краще використовувати час
дослідницька інфраструктура виробляє більше
виходи та виходи кращої якості ми
бачили
у випадку нашого партнерства
обладнання та підвищення якості
і за кількістю публікацій
якщо ви вирішили вибрати автономний
дослідницькі інфраструктури у вашій країні
у будь-якому випадку це a
дуже
корисний крок для наук
інтеграція, тому що знову через відкриту
доступ, який ви матимете, ви будете розміщувати
ваші дослідницькі інфраструктури
науковців від міжнародного користувача
спільноти у вас буде найкраще
науковці, які приходять використовувати ваші дослідження
інфраструктури і в обмін на те, що ви
отримаєте знання знання
на наукову тематику по підготов
зразків, щоб ви завжди навчалися і там
це дуже корисний обмін, коли у вас є
програми відкритого доступу
ви також можете співпрацювати з іншими
дослідницькі інфраструктури, і це допомагає
в
залучення зовнішнього фінансування ми
називати їх користувачами, але користувачі є
дослідники – це професори
ті, які подають пропозиції
фінансування, тож якщо у вас є
хороша мережа, швидше за все, ви
буде
включені або запрошені взяти участь у а
консорціуму подати заявку на зовнішнє фінансування
і кінцевим кроком є ​​також
брати участь як член
в існуючій інфраструктурі або a
європейський консорціум, як у нашому випадку але
також в іншому вигляді
міжнародні дослідницькі інфраструктури
і з членством ви відкриваєте ціле
новий набір можливостей
співпраця сама по собі дуже хороша, і це
допомагає створювати мережі, але коли ви
є членом у вас є рішення в
наукова стратегія дослідження
інфраструктури, і ви також активні
участь у всіх спільних програмах спільних
дослідження
ми приєдналися до кандидатів наук
може бути багато оновлень
приладдя будь-що
будь-яка країна може приєднатися до розмови Еріка
конкретно про європейку Еріка
консорціуми дослідницької інфраструктури
хоча в них є цей європеєць
назви будь-яка країна, до якої може приєднатися, але не є
має бути рішення уряду
Члени erics є країнами так
країні потрібно прийняти деякі
умови, і я торкнуся їх у
наступний слайд і важливо, що я був
приємно почути також попереднє
питання про інвестиції, тому що
вимагають дослідницькі інфраструктури
амбіції амбітні інвестиції для
налаштування зазвичай це інфраструктури
які унікальні та великі
але для цього також потрібна постійна
інвестиції для підтримки функціонування
дослідницькі інфраструктури на вершині
рівень
інакше вони залишаються застарілими з часом
якщо підтримки недостатньо
зараз європейські дослідження
інфраструктурний консорціум заснований на a
регламент Європейської ради
так для всіх
члени європейського союзу це
застосовується негайно, положення застосовується
і є ефективним
для нечленів європейського союзу
є необхідність підписатися
лист про те, що країна
визнає правосуб'єктність і
повна дієздатність а
Ерік
і що це також
забезпечить еквівалентне лікування an
Еріка як міжнародного органу або
міжнародної організації з повагою
до звільнення від
v8 та акцизи це a
Особливість країни Еріка
не може застосовувати віт і акцизні збори до an
Ерік
і є ще один виняток
що з державних закупівель
Директиву Еріка можна придбати
з повагою до всіх європейців
принципи, але вони можуть мати свої власні
процедури, яких їм не потрібно дотримуватися
громадський
процедури закупівлі
та більше деталей у Еріка Ерік
практичні вказівки і є
посилання тут
і це також важливо знати
це формально з точки зору
регламенту, але потім кожен Ерік
можуть мати власні внутрішні процедури
прийняти
нових членів
зараз я також зараз обговорю
співпраця з серіалом Ерік і
спочатку я познайомлю що
selik - це ми центральноєвропейські
консорціум дослідницької інфраструктури
наразі ми маємо вісім членів
країни, і ви бачите їх у
карта
і ми є розподіленим дослідженням
інфраструктури єдиного дослідження
інфраструктури, яка розташована в більш
країни, і ми є єдиним записом
вказують на понад 50 додаткових
інструменти, тому що ми додали більше
в цій школі
і
ми базуємо
у нас є послуги для всіх сфер
наукові мультидисциплінарні дослідження
тому передові матеріали біоматеріали і
нанотехнології і тепер ми з того часу
останній за останні два роки ми маємо
також спеціалізувалися трохи більше на
енергію ми робимо також серію ух
розвиток інфраструктури буде більше
підходить для більш раннього дослідження
внести свій вклад в зелену угоду
принцип кремнезему такий
це один заклад на країну
є винятком cerec в erik there
немає обмежень щодо цього, але ми маємо
один заклад на країну і немає
переказ грошей cerec заснований на
дохідні внески
що це означає, що країни
сприяти
підтримання дослідницької інфраструктури
і присвятити час цьому дослідженню
інфраструктура та персонал цього
дослідницька інфраструктура
і
це єдиний їхній обов'язок
далеко
і ми, звичайно, пропонуємо безкоштовні та
відкритий доступ
на основі якості вибору якість є
єдиного критерію немає іншого
критерій на основі країни
походження чи що завгодно
важливо сказати, що потрібен доступ
бути безкоштовним для користувачів, тому що ви
відразу зрозуміють, що немає
відшкодування країнам за дані
час, який вони надають, є натурою
і ми також працюємо на даний момент підтримується
за рахунок фінансового внеску від
приймаючою країною, якою є Італія
місце знаходиться в Італії, а ми
обговорення фінансових внесків в
майбутнє для членів спільноти
програми чи спільні дослідження, але це так
поки не ефективний
і ми також отримали кошти
від європейської комісії
вони співфінансували наш розвиток
через проект прискорити
де ми розвиваємо це дуже приємно
співпраця з україною зараз в
рамки цього проекту, який триває протягом
чотири роки
мета частини, яка була
пов'язаних із співпрацею з
Україна мала створювати мости і до
розширити наукову співпрацю
з україною, а також зменшити
бар'єри, які заважають укр
дослідників від доступу до наших
об'єктів, про які ми згадували раніше
той факт, що ці заклади мають свої
процеси, які потрібно застосувати, і це може бути
складно, якщо не підготуватися
відбулося створення ан
форпост в україні aceric форпост так
Першим кроком було навчання тренерів
гм
різні люди з
ушорадський університет слідувати безладним
зимова школа, яка є школою а
навчальна школа на нейтронному сонячному центрі
радіація
і
також пройдіть навчання, працюючи в
Університет Чарльза це інше
інший об'єкт у консорціумі
навчання тому, як користуватися інструментами
тоді вони зможуть стежити за користувачами
натомість був також більш широкий
навчання в
для людських ресурсів
в інших темах ні
конкретно наука, але загалом для
приклад дослідження ділових подій
мережеві події
тренінги з інших аспектів, як
управління та облік доходів
внески міжнародної мобільності і
і інші
і
ми організували багато роз’яснювальних робіт
діяльність
від усіх заходів проекту
вісім заходів були організовані безпосередньо
форпост в україні і на 50 більше
50 відсотків учасників всім
роз’яснювальні заходи, які ми організували
в проекті
звідки з цієї застави
подій і 92 відсотки були з України
а потім побачимо, як це буде
вплив на нашу базу користувачів
проект, який має проект прискорення
закінчився в червні, але ми продовжуємо це
співпраця
ми вже бачили різну українську
дослідники приєднуються до семінару, який ми
було лише два дні тому
тому було дуже приємно це бачити
продовжується після завершення проекту
і
ми розглядаємо також як крок
вперед це
Україна приєдналася б як член
Ерік або
що
в
національний об'єкт буде приєднатися як
пов'язаний об'єкт, але це, звичайно
мали б для них менший вплив
переваги
ми
вважають що
об’єкт необхідно розвивати
далі, але, звичайно, це пов’язано з
значний
інвестиції так якби україна стала
входить до складу консорціуму
для цього потрібні інвестиції
об'єкт бути
привабливий унікальний і доповнює
всі засоби, які ми маємо
є крок затвердження від
наш міжнародний науковий і
технічний консультативний комітет, який каже
чи
претенденти нові об'єкти можуть бути
включені чи ні, якщо вони варті того
вони додадуть цінності консорціуму
професор ізак був запрошений до
представити свої плани розвитку
науковий міжнародний вибачте
міжнародний науково-техн
консультативного комітету та для обговорення майбутнього
розвитку подій
і його також запросять приєднатися до
рада директорів департаменту
об'єктів
ось де всі директори
у нас є різні
країни зустрічаються і вирішують, що він буде
спостерігач але
це також допоможе йому зрозуміти
вимір усіх можливостей
за приєднання до Еріка
що ми бачили в минулому
україною, а також з іншими партнерами
в цих діаграмах
в
апеча сині смуги
– відсоток претендентів з
україни
від загальної кількості претендентів
і ви бачите, що проект прискорення
розпочато у 2017 році
і ми сказали, що були всі ці події
цільове навчання на основі інформації та
ви бачите, як відсоток претендентів
з україни росте постійно
це дуже хороший знак на діаграмі
нижче в червоних смугах це
успіх
це показник того, скільки їх
додатків
із загальних заявок, які були
успішно від
учасників з будь-якої точки світу
і більшість з них були українцями і тут
також ви бачите, що є стійкий
збільшити цей параметр ще більше
важливий, ніж попередній, тому що
це означає, що програми є
успішно, тому є
процес навчання
у 2020 році ми бачимо зниження, тому що
на жаль, через covid деякі з наших
об'єкти закриті не були
прийом зовнішніх користувачів
так мабуть
більш цілеспрямоване застосування тим більше
цільових об'єктів з боку укр
користувачів було закрито
пару місяців і ви побачите нижче
прийняття
відсоток загалом
тепер можливості для України в
приєднання до cerec, як ми сказали
вільний відкритий доступ, який вони могли б мати
до дослідницьких інфраструктур, які є
в україні немає
це таке існує така можливість
існує вже зараз, тому нічого немає
запобігання подачі заявок українським користувачам
на наші об'єкти, але
коли є членство, є
міцніший зв'язок зв'язок с
директори біржі
програми все набагато простіше
стає більше
негайно, тобто
вони ближче знайомляться з усіма
засоби так
це одразу
зростає успішність і рівень
додатки ростуть і спільнота є
розвивається локально
їхнє членство відкриється
цілий ряд можливостей
це було б
ще більше розширити можливості за допомогою
інтеграція та відкритий доступ зараз
інтеграція означає також спільний розвиток
приладобудування лабораторій т.ст
об'єкт стає більш актуальним на a
європейському рівні, а також є
обмін ноу-хау між
різні дослідницькі інфраструктури, які
дозволити
мати проекти, яких немає
можливі оновлення, які неможливі
тому що у вас може бути не все
необхідні компетенції
зазвичай всередині проходить навчання
чотири члени
ну в різних техніках використання
приладдя, а також є
важливий аспект привабливості о
зовнішнє фінансування як тому, що як
член нашого європейського дослідження і
приймальний консорціум
ви можете стати помітнішим і більше
привабливий, але й тому, що як яйце ми
можна подати заявку
для фінансування бути бенефіціаром і принести
всі зручності з нами
іноді наші партнери не могли
наші партнерські заклади не могли подати заявку
окремо, тому що вони не актуальні
достатньо, щоб подати заявку самостійно в консорціумі
але ми як консорціум є актуальними
партнера, щоб відкривати нові можливості
а також є спільні кандидати наук і
діяльність з розвитку, яка зазвичай є
зарезервовано для членів, для яких вони не відкриті
об'єкти співпраці
а також ми беремо участь у проекті, який
займається відкритою наукою та відкритими даними ми
зараз розвиваються всі
інфраструктуру, щоб зробити дані справедливими
добре, тому робимо багаторазове використання
і
доступні відразу після ембарго
період, тож це підвищує довіру
з
науки
і ми зараз
об'єднатися з іншими п'ятьма
s3 інфраструктури, тому найбільша
інфраструктури в Європі і ми є
намагаючись приєднатися до стандартів і мати
все готове для підключення до
eos
та європейська хмара відкритої науки та
бути відкритим, щоб бути готовим поставити все
наші дані відкриті в європейському відкритому
наукова хмара з наступного року
я думаю, що це
це з мого боку
тому я радий відповісти, якщо такі є
питання
дуже дякую це було дуже
цікавої багато корисної інформації
і маємо дійсно
з вашої презентації видно, що вона повна
членство в інфраструктурі Еріка Серріка
надає учасникам багато
можливості моє питання
можливо, ви могли б дати якийсь шматочок
поради українським дослідникам
що потрібно зробити, щоб певний
наукова група або центр використання
обладнання в україні можна було б приєднатися і знайти
таких партнерів
що можете порадити будь ласка
добре, як наукова група, я вважаю
ти
означають ті, що мають значні
дослідницька інфраструктура для приєднання a
консорціум
зазвичай створюються посилання
за спорідненістю в нашому випадку було таке
спорідненість тем дослідження з
усородський національний університет
у них була давня співпраця
з одним із наших партнерів Чарльзом
університет у Празі і
з цього ми почали співпрацю, але
як я сказав, наслідки того, що ви можете
досягти ефекту, який ти можеш
досягти
через
єдина співпраця не порівнянна
до того, що ви можете отримати, будучи членом
однієї з цих дослідницьких інфраструктур
звісно, ​​вам потрібно більше займатися
бо має бути фінансування
для
належного користувача послуг це означає, що
на об’єкті потрібен персонал
вони готові та доступні для обслуговування
зовнішні дослідники, які можуть не знати
як користуватися інструментами, як
потім обробляти дані, щоб вони вимагали
багато ресурсів
але
з іншого боку
скажімо, що повна користь повна
вплив
що ви можете отримати через
членство
а не через єдину співпрацю
тому що співробітництво зазвичай має a
обмежений обсяг, коли членство має a
ширший обсяг
дуже дякую, Арнела
згадати це дуже важливо
і я також почув одну з укр
проекти у вашій презентації, яка є
беручи участь
пан Василь Різак
тому я дякую за вашу презентацію та
а тепер надамо слово пану Василю Хе
також приєднається до нас онлайн і розповість нам
більше про їхній досвід
який був їхній досвід, будь ласка
Дозвольте представити вам пана Василя Різака
так завідувач кафедри твердого стану
електроніка та інформаційна безпека о
Ушкарський національний університет
містер Василь Рексак розкажіть нам про
співробітництво в Cerec eric
і
будь ласка, ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
ваша презентація
ми з нетерпінням чекаємо пана Василя
перебування в мережі
сподіваюся, що досвід укр
дослідники, які вже мали
можливість працювати
в діапазоні від
дослідницька інфраструктура буде справді
корисний для нас
також
ми чули від міс Арнели
що не так просто приєднатися до a
дослідницька інфраструктура
тому що існує певна процедура
чого потрібно дотримуватися
крім того є питання, пов'язані з
фінансування, наскільки я розумію
тож добрий день
ми бачимо тебе
наскільки я розумію, у нас були
невелика технічна затримка, і ми зробимо це
змирися з цим
так
чи з'єднання в порядку
[Музика]
Гаразд
надамо слово
спікер пан василь слово ваша
ласкаво просимо
ну
дякую дякую це просто так
ми маємо гм одночасно
інтерпретуючи так, якщо пропустити
будь ласка, пане Василь
зробіть свою презентацію українською так і
всі учасники залежно від
мова зможе їх послухати
до вашої презентації в будь-якому
українська чи англійська без проблем, крім вас
знайте, що все залежить від вас
тож продовжимо
перш за все хотів би щиро
дякую організатору цього заходу за
можливість презентувати результати
нашої команди
взаємодія співпраці з Сирією
Каррік
я хотів би ще раз поговорити від
назва нашої команди uh судно rusek і
інші люди, які брали участь
гм в цьому
створення цієї презентації
так кілька слів з історії
ідея створення лабораторії
прийшли з
Володимир Маталін, професор
Карлов університет у Празі
спочатку як спільна лабораторія двох
університети
під час роботи над контрактом нова ідея
виникла
відкрити цю лабораторію у складі
Консорціум Сари Керік
тут можна побачити професора Володимира
маталін член
Рада директорів Zerick Eric
важко було відмовитися від такої пропозиції
у 2015 році ми разом із нашим ректором
професор Володимир Малянка
збираються в Трієст і
директор представляє наш університет в
засідання загальних зборів
у нас склалося враження про консорціум
чого європейці не очікували
що ушну
був би таким потужним університетом і
угода між Сарою Керік і
був підписаний
і процес почався
таким чином ми потрапили в команду
важковаговиків європейської науки
ну на попередній презентації, як ми
чути було багато хороших слів
гм
розповіла про саму Сару Керрік
так
ми б пропустили ті слайди, які були
представлений ух
про Сару Керрік і перейти на
прискорити сам проект
тому я хочу підкреслити, що це було
під час підготовки та реалізації
угоди між сарікариком і
ужну
домовленості про участь наших
держава
на горизонті 2020 року
програма
було підписано між Україною та ЄС
наша команда була практично однією з
першим серед українських вчених
вступити до програми віку 2020
нашими партнерами є вчені з
італія швеція нідерланди
Великобританія Німеччина тощо
прискорити проект
пакети включають
підтримання і
стійкість дослідницьких структур
сприяння відкритому науковому простору
залучення нових користувачів, зокрема шляхом
вилуговування
і сприяння практичному використанню
результати проекту
прискорити досягнення цілей
ну
ми могли б
Назвіть довгострокову стійкість
дослідницькі інфраструктури юридичні та
адміністративні проекти
підвищення прозорості дослідження
інфраструктури
розвиток
методика вимірювання
соціально-економічний вплив
нарощування потенціалу за допомогою тренінгів
працівників і користувачів
одне із завдань нашого проекту
прискорити було
створення цього сталого
Церекарічний форпост в україні
створено цей форпост
на кафедрі твердого стану
електроніка
та інформаційна безпека ужерт
університету на базі обладнання
що інші члени cerec передадуть
нам
завдяки цьому ми можемо працювати над сучасним
обладнання в європейській наук
установ
доступ у практичний
практично необмежений
ну насправді ми не встигаємо
обробляти вже отримані масиви даних
наприклад
ці слайди
показати результат досліджень
взаємодії між біомолекулами
і поверхня оксиду титану
я повільно піду до слайдів
тому результати цих досліджень є
встановлення характеру
мікроскопічний
механізм
взаємодій аденіну
з поверхнею оксиду титану
однак згідно з попереднім
аналіз
не дуже приємний висновок був
отримано утворення хім
зв'язок між молекулами ДНК і титаном
оксид
але
разом з ух з цим ми отримали
багато позитивних емоцій
кошти на проїзд до європейських ух
наукових установ заробітна плата
конференції
оргтехніка
ну окрема стаття
на обладнанні
тож ось список гм
новинні сайти
що
пишіть про нас
і
ну ось зображення
гм
національний університет
що нагородив професор Володимир
Маталіну присвоєно звання dr honoris causa
за його активну участь
у міжнародному науковому співробітництві
ми підготували кімнату для нового
обладнання
і, як бачите, встановлено та налаштовано
обладнання тут
тож зараз почнеться відео
я б припустив
створення в єдиному комплексі
обладнання для
серпнева спектрометрія
магнетронне розпилення та мас
спектрометрія
підходять до кінця
тож остаточний звіт про акселерацію
проект стверджує е
плани підтримки sarikaric
нашого форпосту
тому ми активно працюємо над цим питанням
як стати партнером sarikarik для
україни і наш форпост
ми визнаємо, що для того, щоб бути uh
актуальне для Сари Керрік є
необхідно знайти нашу дослідницьку нішу серед
різноманітні інструменти та техніки
доступний у Sarah Carrick, тому ми
разом із Сарою Керрік
представники, зокрема з чех
республіки проведено
аналіз територій саріка
дослідження
і як результат пропонується встановити
лабораторія застави
для відновлюваних джерел енергії
як компонент серії Carrick у нас добре
це ми збираємося оновити наш
наукове обладнання
і зробити прискорення cerec
регіональна форпостна інфраструктура
ми сподіваємося
це дозволяє стати членом cerric
для України та партнерського об'єкта
Сари Керік для форпостної лабораторії
зокрема ми збираємося обладнати
заставна лабораторія с
дослідження передового обладнання
наприклад, модель магнетронного розпилення
сучасне обладнання для проведення рентген
дифракція
і розсіювання е
характеристика
сканування електронної та атомної сили
мікроскопи
ми сподіваємося, що наш інфраструктурний проект
та подана пропозиція
для
конкурсний відбір в рамках ЄС
інструмент зовнішньої дії отримає
фінансова підтримка
у випадку
успіху ми плануємо провести комплекс
дослідження
на заставі лабораторії створення
тонкі та наноплівкові активні елементи
сонячні панелі
який включає кілька послідовних
етапи отримання зразка
ну до вивчення структурних
організація
з тонких і безперервних
наноплівка
це може бути попереднім або власним
етап для ух експериментальних досліджень з використанням
ух синхротронне випромінювання
буде дуже цікавий для обох
український
та європейських дослідників, які працюють у
галузь прикладного матеріалознавства
плановане дослідження відповідає с
горизонт європи
Програмна місія народного господарства
стратегія
до 2030 року
як ініціативи
вони були європейською зеленою угодою
цілі
щодо акредитації
istac
ми сподіваємося, що наявність таких
обладнання значно збільшує
ймовірність прискорення цього
лабораторія
за міжнародними науковими і
технічний консультативний комітет
ми дуже вдячні
до
заступник міністра з питань європейської інтеграції
Алексі Скарато
і
виконавчий директор сарик
Іанна дзвонить
за їх активну
інтерес і велика підтримка
Дякуємо Вам за
увагу
ми відкриті для вашого запитання
Дуже дякую
це було дуже цікаво і важливо
інформація, яку ми бачили і
справді українські університети
є обладнання, яке використовується для
сучасні наукові дослідження
і наукові групи мають
можливість приєднатися до європ
інфраструктури
і у мене є коротке запитання, що ти зробив
почніть з того, якщо ви можете почати з цього
будь ласка
з чого ти почав
ми почали 20 років тому
коли
наші студенти
почався
відвідування європейських університетів
дякую дякую я в цьому впевнений
всім буде справді цікаво
дізнатись більше про свій досвід
тому я думаю, що ваша презентація була дуже
цікавий для багатьох
і
я хотів це сказати
українські дослідники не працюють
тільки в апаратній інженерії
в
дослідницькі інфраструктури, які базуються
по техніці, але й україна відома
у своєму IT секторі
цифровізація є
слово, яке не потребує перекладу
український
всі ми зараз і зараз я б хотів
надати слово
до старшого наукового співробітника
офіцер гігантської мережі Кріс Артетон
я сподіваюся, що ти зможеш
приєднуйся до нас скоро, Кріс
ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
ваш
презентація
підтримка дослідницьких напрямків у IT-сфері
привіт Кріс
тому ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
щоб почути вашу презентацію на тему
гігантська мережа, які можливості
для українських дослідників і, можливо
є можливості з'єднання
співробітництво з україною будь ласка
підлога твоя
так гм
так, мене звати Кріс Атертон, я
старший спеціаліст із наукової роботи з
shand
і я сьогодні тут, щоб поговорити з вами
акуляча мережа
у вас буде презентація
ділитись
так
він має відображатися зараз
добре, я почну як я
вважаю, що зараз має працювати
так хто такий гігант, я думаю, що це a
добре
хм, для початку з того, хто ми є
Асоціація гігантів – це спільна робота
європейські національні дослідження та освіта
мережі
ми підтримуємо розвиток досліджень
та освітні інновації
але в глобальному масштабі
разом ми надаємо інформацію
екосистема
інфраструктури та послуг
використовується для комунікаційної співпраці
обмін даними та доступ до
послуги та засоби сховища
але витоки гіганта
повернутися до перших днів
Інтернет
але спочатку я просто хотів згадати
цей гігант є членською організацією
складається з понад 40 національних досліджень і
освітні мережі з усієї Європи
разом ми підтримуємо близько десяти тисяч
установ і близько п'ятдесяти млн
користувачів
і як я згадував раніше
ми маємо своє походження
від початку Інтернету
коли був побудований церн
колайдер частинок на кордоні
між Францією та Швейцарією
дані були поширені в ум
дякую, що поставили лайк
гм так вибачте так гм
cern був підключений спочатку
це на кордоні між Францією та
Швейцарія та дані, які були
згенерований з cern потрібно було поділитися
глобально з усіма партнерами, які
працював над цим величезним експериментом
і
наприкінці 80-х початку 90-х років
а
була створена спеціально дослідницька мережа
щоб допомогти перемістити ці дані, називається
Європейська академічна дослідницька мережа
і вони були створені у співпраці
з 19 національними науковими та освітніми
мереж у той час, тож, якщо ви уявляєте, a
національна мережа об'єднує всі
університети всі дослідження
інститути
державні установи гм
в країні
а потім магістральну мережу
академічна та дослідницька мережа
об’єднує всі ці країни разом
тепер причина чому
для пересування їм потрібна була спеціальна мережа
ці дані з цієї причини
я зараз перейду
як є дослідницька мережа
побудований відрізняється від комерційного
мережі
робота, яку потребують дослідники
дуже відрізняються від тих, що a
комерційний
користувач має
зазвичай кажучи для реклами
мережі, якщо ви подивитеся на графік даних
що передається по мережі it
виглядає як хвиля
бувають піки вдень і
мінімуми протягом ночі
але дослідники не діють
просто
вдень надходять дані дослідження
надсилається в будь-який час доби і
є багато даних, які надсилаються
тому ми провели тест у 2017 році і перемістили 100
терабайт даних
Женева
до Канберри в Австралії
так, як академічні та дослідницькі
мережа працює нормально
але в цьому випадку ми купили два
комерційні підключення до мережі
тепер першому вдалося отримати лише a
пропускна здатність близько двох гігабіт на
по-друге, це
наче дуже добре для реклами
мережі, але це не фантастично
тому що решта цих 10 гігабіт
з'єднання насправді не використовувалося
і якщо ви думаєте, що цей зв'язок
може бути тільки 10 концертів локально, але піти
у всіх мережах
вся решта реклами
Інтернет, щоб досягти кінцевої точки
в Австралії
Є точки, в яких це не 10
гігабіт або він може бути перевантажений або або
будь-що інше, що обмежує
пропускна здатність даних
коли ми порівнювали це з гігантом
мережі ми змогли досягти a
пропускна здатність близько 10 гігабіт на
по-друге, це про
9,27 гігабіт в секунду, що дуже добре
близько до того, що обіцяли, що
ми доставили
і гм з точки зору швидкості, з якою
що знадобиться для переміщення цих даних
від
Женеви аж до Канберри
для enrons це займе приблизно один і a
півдня
тоді як для комерційних провайдерів
що ми порівняли з цим
візьміть найшвидшого не менше семи
півтора дня на переміщення даних
це лише свідчить про те, що є
конкретні вимоги від дослідження
спільнота про підключення і це
чому так важливо мати a
спеціалізована мережа, щоб допомогти
дослідники
виконувати роботу, яку їм потрібно зробити, тому що
кожному потрібно підключення до Інтернету
щоб поділитися даними
зараз
я згадував, що було 19 ум
країни, які спочатку почали
мережа зросла до 46
але з тих 46 країн цей гігант
з'єднується разом, ми потім з'єднуємо їх
46 до решти світу
і
в'язниця не тільки з'єднує
гм
решта світу але
ти знаєш з
достатня потужність, але це a
кілька сотень гігабітних підключень так
на даний момент ми підключилися до понад 140
країн у всьому світі через наш регіональний
партнерів
гм, і ми передаємо приблизно терабайт в секунду
даних у нашій мережі
і ми також працюємо з великим ух
вибачте великі дослідницькі організації
які охоплюють декілька країн, як-от cern
Європейське космічне агентство eu metsat
масив квадратних кілометрів і багато багатьох
більше
ми працюємо з партнерами в іншому світі
регіонів, щоб допомогти створити глобальні дослідження
допомогти створити глобальні дослідження та
освітня спільнота
як в африці в азії
північ і Латинську Америку і так ми проходимо
ці дані вільно між собою
принести користь розвитку науки
глобально, і ми робимо це, працюючи над
проекти
зараз один такий проект, який актуальний
бо для україни зветься вепом
підключити проект
зараз він перебуває на другому етапі з приблизно
10 10 з половиною мільйонів євро або 95
відсоток з яких оплачується за
dg біля um дирекції від с
Європейського Союзу та інших п'яти
відсотків від внеску
внески з країн
які беруть участь у цій ум
проект, одним із яких є Україна
і цей проект спрямований на подолання
цифровий розрив, допомагаючи цим
країни для підключення інтегрувати і
зміцнюватися з ширшим європейським і
глобальна дослідницька та освітня спільнота
але jayant - це не просто мережа
і це не просто професіонал, це ще й а
проект
е, який також називають ув'язненим і це
складається з співробітників з європейських ух
член національного дослідження та освіти
мережі, а також гігант
організації, тому я сам працюю всередині
проект xiaomi
разом ми розробили послуги та
і
інфраструктура, яка потрібна дослідникам
виконувати свою роботу, щоб перемістити їх
великий
обсяги даних по всьому світу
плавно
і що я збираюся робити
сьогодні я хочу дати вам пару випадків
вивчає один для геонауки, а інший для
астрономії
який, я сподіваюся, дає вам уявлення про
вплив, який підключений до enron
може мати
тож, по-перше, ширший момент про
геонаука і чому ми це важливо
геонауки для вирішення трьох великих глобальних
кидає виклик катастрофам і надзвичайним ситуаціям
реагування на сталий розвиток і
зміна клімату
ці глобально адресовані о, вибачте ці
глобально вирішуються політичними
фреймворки, такі як фреймворк сендай
Паризька кліматична угода
та сталий розвиток 17 ООН
цілі
але нам потрібні дані, щоб зрозуміти
і підтвердити те, що відбувається
і ця область геонауки називається
спостереження за землею
і допомога nren зрушити цю землю
дані спостережень із джерел даних
ну зазвичай
як із супутників і космосу
які надсилають дані на землю ми
потім перейдіть від наземних станцій до
переробні потужності, але й ми
допомогти перенести дані з обробки
засоби для широкого поширення навколо
світ до користувачів
і ці дані, які використовуються
дослідницькі групи
виконувати свої дослідження та робити
аналіз, щоб допомогти особам, які приймають рішення
одним із таких прикладів є переміщення даних до і
від європейського центру за серед
діапазон прогнозів погоди
інакше відомий як ecnwf
ecmwf відстежує зміни клімату як частину
проект Коперника, тож це a
багато мільярдів євро
проект, який фінансує супутники
у просторі та поширення ух
даних вільно та відкрито uh to uh to
світ гм
для використання в
щоб подолати ці три великі проблеми
ecm wf uh відстежуйте довгострокові зміни в
середні погодні умови
і з 1997 року як глобальний
спільноти ми погодилися, що зміни
середня температура поверхні становить a
прямий результат техногенних викидів
це має прямий вплив на
таких місцях, як Нідерланди або
Мальдіви
де рівень моря може почати підніматися
і
те саме в
україни
все це впливає на те, що ми залишаємо
майбутні покоління
і спостереження за землею допомагають нам бачити
земля
більш детально
не лише на макрорівні, а й надалі
далі в
тепер ось зображення з одного з них
супутники, один із цих дозорних
супутники, що входять до складу
проект Коперника
гм
тут можна побачити діоксид азоту
який був
виділяється двигунами внутрішнього згоряння по всій території
континент європи
з такими даними ми зараз бачимо
звідки надходять викиди
які міста найбільше забруднюють
і це також дозволяє дослідникам
виміряти також вплив уряду
рішення
здійснюється обмін цими даними
можливо з дослідниками
завдяки національним дослідженням і
освітні мережі
наприклад 80
з усіх даних з
супутники Коперника йде до
дослідників через загальну мережу
і пов'язаних n прогонів
решта користувачів отримують свої дані через
комерційний товарний інтернет
дані, отримані Коперником
супутники допомагає в таких речах, як
дослідження морського життя землетрусів
прогноз атмосфери та погоди як ух
я показав
до ум змін у використанні землі ух
стале сільське господарство і багато багатьох
більше гм
один приклад, який ви можете використати та
це
є
більше
актуально на сьогодні
ось як це
може використовуватися в україні, тому xiao надає
членів прямого підключення до
набори даних із Землі Коперника
програма спостереження як від ESA, так і від
від umitzat це не тільки підтримує
дослідження, але також надає можливості
за ну для нового
дослідницькі ініціативи і це a
дійсно цінна співпраця, яку ми маємо
як з esa, так і з umatat доставити
ці дані до дослідників
гм
це зображення на
ліва сторона
це дані від Коперника, що було
передані через наші мережі
це показує сезонне значення
антициклон і вихори в чорному
море
і ці дані були отримані з uh
супутникова система topx poseidon, яка
є спільним
місія NASA і ESA
і це частина морського Коперника
служба моніторингу навколишнього середовища де
ця інформація походить з
ці дані можуть бути використані дослідниками для
визначити сезонні течії
і на основі цього вони можуть порадити е
уряди, а також бізнес
щодо політики доставки та маршрутів доставки
тому що ви можете розставити пріоритети або
спрямовувати, куди йдуть кораблі, щоб зменшити
кількість викидів, які надаються
вимкніть, використовуючи струми в
Чорне море для ефективної навігації
а не
проштовхування та використання більше енергії
і створюючи більше вуглекислого газу і
оксиду азоту в результаті
з
рухи
тому ці th це трохи приклад
про те, як можна використовувати Коперник
інформація, яка впливає на прийняття рішень
а також допомогти впоратися з цими трьома
великі виклики
один приклад, який ми маємо з раніше
цього року
до якого я брав участь, мав допомогти встановити
створити новий тип мережевого підключення
між
Європа та Латинська Америка, тож ми просто
побудував новий кабель між
португалія та бразилія
називається кабель Bella
і
це дозволяє нам
спільною ємністю в сотні терабайт
між двома континентами
також у сотнях сотень терабайт
гігабайт це приблизно чотири uh 4,7
терабайт ємності за посиланням
і
саме цьому ми присвятили a
канал лише для даних Коперника
і це дозволяє нам переміщувати дані
зберігається в Греції, де один
з
розташовано джерела даних Copernicus
аж до дзеркальних сайтів у
Латинська Америка
гм
показали початкові результати
що є підвищена пропускна здатність і
зменшення затримки за рахунок надсилання
дані через цей новий кабель і результати
це дуже багатообіцяюче
крок можливостей для Латинської Америки і
дослідження в цілому
це зараз добре це завдяки
робота і залучення в
глобальна спільнота enron
і в цьому полягає суть глобального дослідження
і освітня мережева спільнота може
обробляти ці великі потоки даних
сотні гігабіт даних
гм
котрий
певним чином можуть також комерційні провайдери
використання
але не обов'язково в однаковій мірі
кабель Bella означає це
дослідникам буде безперешкодно
регіональні та міжконтинентальні
інфраструктура, яка існує
а дослідники в україні можуть безпосередньо
Використовуйте цей кабель при роботі і
співпрацювати з глобальними партнерами в
Латинська Америка
праворуч – перше зображення
що було надіслано по кабелю
і якщо ви отримаєте копію слайдів
у примітках є посилання, де ви
можна завантажити це
цей файл це кілька сотень
мегабайт розміром
але переходимо до астрономії
є один приклад, який я хотів би
дати вам ух, як ух глобального гм
охоплення enrons uh дійсно допомагає
цей приклад використовує um the
Європейська гравітаційна обсерваторія
називається Virgo, який знаходиться в Італії
цей сайт підключений до локального
enron гар
італійські дослідження та освіта
мережі, але вона також використовує спец
послуга під назвою edu gain яка
Спільнота nren розвинулась і працює
edugain дозволяє дослідникам використовувати його
ім'я користувача та пароль для доступу до всіх
веб-платформи та дослідницькі послуги
які пов’язані з ним іншим чином
як єдиний вхід
або федеративний доступ
система вимагає участі
університети та установи для управління
власних користувачів
але це зменшує навантаження на
дослідницький проект
і
та інші види співпраці, щоб це зробити
легше отримати дослідницькі проекти
участь з інших регіонів світу
якщо ці університети є
ну частина освіти
а також для університетів та наукових досліджень
інститутів, це надає доступ до ширшого
спектр доступних послуг
можливо на місцевому чи національному рівні
і після налаштування не повинно бути зайвих
адміністративне навантаження на особистість
інститут провайдера
повертаючись до Діви
щодо
лютий
2020 рік
вибач 2021
налічує понад 650 членів
представляє 119 установ з 14
різні країни
які є частиною цієї співпраці
Я збираюся розглянути один приклад
pidius
так
Кріс, мені дуже шкода, але ми
дуже багато з
ми чутливі до розкладу
так е
чи це
але я не можу не запитати у вас одне дуже
коротке запитання
на вашу думку
можуть українські вчені завдяки
залучення до гігантської мережі
запуск нових цифрових послуг
який зараз дуже популярний в i.t
як ти гадаєш
найкраще було б зробити
Поговори з
euron українське дослідження та
освітня мережа
у них є засоби та засоби
ну вміння
для підключення до xiaomi та для підключення до
ширші глобальні дослідження та
освітня спільнота
велике дякую, Кріс, сподіваюся
презентацію, яку ви нам зробили
також буде доступним для нашої аудиторії
ну
добре роздивитися і побачити що
інший
можливості гігант дає українцям
дослідники, вчені, а також ви
згаданий
підключити електронний додаток і
в кімнаті у нас є представник
цей проект
ВООЗ
можна розповісти більше про це так
Ну
якщо з тобою все гаразд, я даю
слово наступному спікеру, якому я даю
поверх до yevgenpro
виконавчий директор
асоціація уран
про його підключення до електронної програми
я хотів би взяти участь у проекті
продовжуй завжди сказав Кріс
що вже знають українські освітяни
україни як представники ух
уран і європа з'єднуються
так
пару слів про нашу організацію
в першу чергу наша організація має a
стан вітчизняних досліджень і
освітня мережа
це абревіатура від
національна дослідницька та академічна мережа
ми надали доступ до високошвидкісного gm
канали та надавати цифрові послуги
спеціально для освіти та науки
сечі є НГО, заснованим вищ
навчальний заклад четвертого
рівень акредитації
Національної академії наук потім до
академії педагогічних наук це
є членською організацією з
73 члени відкрито для прийому
нових учасників
будь-який інститут чи університет будь-який
навчальний
асоціація може стати
членом, впливати та сприяти
його діяльність
в
у р а н є членом нац
науково-дослідницьке об'єднання т.л
входить до європейського ЕРГ
інфраструктури
стратегія була
затверджений урядом в україні в
uh квітень 2021 в ap Connects ukraine has
багато можливостей для інтеграції наших
освіти і науки в євро
дослідницька інфраструктура та скоротити
подолати цифровий розрив
дозвольте мені розповісти вам, що таке перспектива
це дати
наші вихователі і
дослідників в Україні
надається важлива сфера діяльності
доступ до високої швидкості і
засоби зв'язку, що дає змогу багатьом з
дослідники, наприклад, фізика
елементарних частинок і ядер
фізики високих енергій на нац
науковий центр під назвою гергіо
фізико-технічний інститут всесвіту
це звичайний українець
група дослідників, що
відстежує та аналізує отримані дані
поворот
і
також запускає його в
далі аналізує першу перемогу
і доступ до цього середовища є
дається через гіганта
мережі
національний університетський двигун у твердій палітурці
дає 10 гігабайт на секунду
канал
потужність
і
в
потенціал становить 40 гігабайт в секунду
збільшиться, виросте ще більше
після гомогенізації коллайдера
ЦЕРН планує завершити роботу до 2027 року
так що розрахунковий комплекс до
так, Keep все ще може бути одним із найкращих
в
розрахунок
середовища та відстоювати укр
репутація на арені на
наукова арена в цій сфері ми
необхідний для підключення укр
розрахункові потужності до 100 гігабайт
за секунду інший приклад gn to
використання з ух корисністю для україни
є університетом Сікорського, який застосовує
подання до міністерства науки і
освіти дослідницький проект на
методологія комплексу моніторингу і
аналізувати кліматичні зміни на основі
супутникові дані, на які ви збираєтеся
використання результатів цього проекту так
добре пропагували стійке
розвиток україни її територій
і безпека критичних
інфраструктури
в умовах критичної зміни клімату
нам потрібна була б ваша послуга
список розсилки medcast від
європейська система
до
використання людського набору
що Кріс Едвардсон так згадав
це майже реальний обмін даними
а для цього знадобиться могутній гігант
канали доступу до них буде
віддано в політехнічний інститут kia
від
уран
крім доступу до високої швидкості
канали уран дає можливість для
унікальний
Gen стандарти це захищений
гм роман
з
безшовні
підключення до Інтернету
чи перебуваєте ви у своєму закладі чи
в якомусь іншому
десятки тисяч точок доступу і
у понад 100 країнах світу Україна
також є в цьому списку
це знову ж таки авторизація
використовує технологію уніфікованого доступу і
дає можливість
користувачів із навчальних закладів
до
прибуток
доступ до всіх ресурсів через один
рахунок, який надається домом
заклад
в Європі освіта є єдиною
вступ на Еразмус плюс
учасників завдяки освіті європ
вже впроваджує цифрову
студентський квиток
безпаперовий erasmus ewpn є захищеним
спосіб
обмін даними для освіти і
наука, навіть якщо ви використовуєте
безкоштовний wi-fi в громадських місцях
авторизація відбувається через гру edu
відправником файлу є служба для
надсилання великих файлів
зазвичай анонімні сервери використовуються як
журнал google disk але вони не є
повністю конфіденційно і не повністю безпечно
і вони не вони своє не підтверджують
особистість відправника
тим часом
в центрі файлів
особа, яка надіслала, завжди ідентифікується
студенти та учасники
отримає доступ до онлайн-сервісів або
купити їх
за особливих умов, і вони будуть
користуватися повною конфіденційністю
персональні дані користувачів
в наукових колах є а
це частина, а не частина ланцюга
додаткова послуга, яка дозволяє
щоб перевірити, чи є одержувач
має право на
знижки, це відбувається через
освіти
я вже згадував, що цього року уран
став членом гігантської інфраструктури
завдяки
два нових канали казино ko
який поширився на європейського гіганта
мережа та збільшення стратегічного значення
нашої країни для гіганта
нове підключення завершує
півколо богари кишанівки м. Познань
і включає першу обл
лінія сполучення між двома сх
країни партнерства по кишану якщо київ
та київ Познань частини
в
потужність лінії 100 гігабайт на
другий
[Музика]
згідно з 15 роком
одна угода ціна до
технології отримають залишиться
те саме
протягом усього цього часу
ця нова технологія використовує
сучасні спектральні технології, що
підвищує потужність лінії завдяки
різної довжини
хвилі
ну введіть гм
це буде близько 400 000 гігабайт на
по-друге, через оновлення
модуль перепідключення так ми
підключиться
дослідницькі та інноваційні центри в
України до гіганта астрономічного
обсерваторії та установи, які потребують
доступ до цифрової європейської
інфраструктури тут medcast kapernick
гм так далі
європейська інтеграція є одним із
тенденції сучасної істор
розвиток збільшення
взаємопов'язаність урядів
в різних сферах, особливо в
освіта і наука європейський вибір
україни
посилює потребу України в європ
інтеграції за підтримки міністерства
освіта в україні
гігант і ваш зв'язок з Іраном
створив технічну і
інформаційна база для обміну
цифрову інформацію та надати
послуги, які уніфіковані з
послуг україни і буде продовжуватися
працює на підтримку громади с
освітян і науковців в україні які
хто проявляє інтерес до
європейське партнерство та ваш
інтеграція дякую
дуже дякую, Mr
yivken шановні колеги
сьогодні
ми чули
багато корисної інформації
ми почали з
зміни в європейському союзі
по-європейськи
Зміни області дослідження упаковані
ми також чули
інформація про нові програми, які
стати доступною для укр
дослідники
і перша частина нашого
подія закінчилася і вона почнеться
з панельною дискусією о 14 год
і мова піде про
запровадження відкритих вивісок в україні дякую
тобі так багато уваги
чудовий день
ти